this unwinding business has become very
popular everybody's talking about
unwinding detoxing and whatever first of
all why are you two so toxic and then
you want to detox yourself you are
eating wrong you're thinking wrong your
emotions are wrong and you talk stuff
and now you want to detox you wind
yourself up and then you want to unwind
winding yourself up is a crime this is
why I am saying why a purpose is
important is if your purpose is really
burning in your heart activity is not
burdensome activity will never be
burdensome you will know the joy of
action because it's not burdensome it's
always you're looking for an opportunity
you are looking for an opportunity to be
on and when I use the word on you're off
means you know what it means no no we
don't want that to happen right away
life is about being on a time will come
to go off after that you can't switch on
again let me remind you all of you many
of you thinking how much should I do how
much should I not do see these questions
will come up only if you don't have a
purpose to fulfill a purpose which is
larger than yourself if you don't have
it in your heart then always the
calculations of what should I do what
should I not do there is no such thing
as on and off you're on when you're
exhausted you'll anyway fall down and
you will get up don't plan all these
unwinding plans when you're exhausted ah
you fall dead and you come awake again
that's how life should be hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because I need it I need it for me
because I don't wake up every day and
say yes let's go conquer the world now I
wake up and and I need that external
motivation to match my internal
motivation when I see somebody who's
doing amazing things it makes me just
want to play a bigger game and so I hope
that today's video makes you want to
play a bigger game too because your
message matters and let's get it out to
the world so today let's get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only sad Guru Joy
the Southerner is uh
essentially towards
using your emotional intelligence
when we say emotional intelligence
today it's being identified in the world
for a long time we thought intelligence
means just
IQ
see this is not a
IQ means I stand in the queue
that means
always behind somebody
this is the nature of the intellect
intellect is always trying to imitate
and be
one up wanting to be better than
somebody
is also an imitation of somebody isn't
it
essentially we are trying to do a little
better than the monkeys
that's evolution
yes
the nature of the intellect is
right now the way it is for most human
beings
it is a useless instrument unless
there is a bank of information
there is no information most people do
not know how to use their intellect
only with information they can use their
intellect
this is not this is not the nature of
emotional intelligence it doesn't need
any information
it can just Embrace everything and know
it
it can feel its way through life
it need not stand in a queue
it need not stand behind somebody it
need not try to be better than somebody
it's simply
a way of being involved with life
knowing Life by involvement not by
dissection
this is the difference between intellect
and emotion
intellect tries to know everything by
cutting it open
by dissections
emotion knows things by Embrace by
inclusion
please
so the southern is essentially to
heighten your emotional intelligence
because it's so much of an easier way of
doing things if you want to dissect the
ultimate
if you want to dissect the divine
that's not a good thing and you won't
get anywhere with it
the best way is to embrace
when you Embrace somebody you are also
allowing yourself to be embraced
otherwise it will not happen
only I will embrace you you cannot
embrace me it doesn't work like that
when I embrace I am also embraced
so this is a way of embracing
the Divine rather than dissecting the
Divine so sadhana is essentially about
this devotion means just that
devotion is not about dissecting the
Divine it's about dancing with the
divine
becoming one with it
essentially
to heighten your emotional intelligence
so that your ability to live well is not
dependent upon being better than
somebody your ability to live well is by
your own innate nature not because you
are better than somebody you don't have
to prove that you're better than
somebody you don't even have to try to
be better than somebody
this is emotional intelligence
there is no hierarchy in this
once intellect enters this
if you say love
who loves most
there is no such thing
do I love Diana linga more
or you love the analinga more
do I love this Turtle more
or you love this Turtle more do I love
this monkey
more or you love this monkey more
nobody can decide this
never ever can anybody wait and say okay
this person loves more than the other
person there is no such thing quantities
do not apply to emotional intelligence
when quantities do not apply the high
and low disappear big and small
disappear
life becomes as it is
and a more important life than you or
you a more important life than the ant
if you think you are more important you
have a gross mind
you do not understand that ant considers
its life as important as you consider
your life probably more
he's got more limbs than you
probably doing more useful things he's
more organized than you we don't know
what else
probably their population is more
if you give them the Voting Rights they
would win hands down
so
intellect is always trying to set one
thing against the other
it is your intellect
which has created conflict
it is your emotion which can bring this
together but
if emotion follows intellect
emotion will also will become a deadly
conflict
if your intellect follows the emotion
then
there would be no conflict there would
be Sweetness in the world there would be
wonderful situations in the world
to the southern eyes essentially
oriented towards that
it's a simple structure
but if you give yourself it does
miraculous things to you
[Music]
a lot of people cannot understand that
something so simple can do
something like this to a human being
because they dissect it and see
if I dissect you on C let us say you are
a great singer
wow you sing so well let me see what is
in your vocal cords and I will dissect
your vocal cords and look in I will not
find any music
because that is not the way life works
so dissection will take you
to a place where everything will become
meaningless
if you apply your intellect to every
aspect of your life you will turn
everything into meaningless rubbish
this is what is happening in the life of
an intellectual
that everything looks meaningless and
rubbish
but if you apply your emotion everything
becomes valuable and beautiful
every little thing becomes a blade of
grass becomes poetry
as simply a wave of the branch becomes a
song
but if you apply your intellect
everything can be reduced to rubbish
everything becomes no good
if you apply your emotion everything
becomes great wherever your desire is
that's where your mind will be
if you desire something intensely your
mind will be always there right now you
desire the cup wrong place to be
you desire a goal that's what you should
desire when you're on the field isn't it
now you can design the cup
but once you're on the field you just
desire the goal and goal and go nothing
else once your desire is strong your
body and mind naturally moves in that
direction isn't it whatever you desire
that's where you go
if your desire falls off then you can't
keep the mind on it so you just have to
develop the icha in you
the only itcher is to score the call
then you don't have to worry about
mental focus that's where the mind will
be
[Music]
can somebody take your mind off what you
desire
what you desire is where your mind will
naturally go isn't it
so how does yoga help in this
see what are the simple parameters with
which the body and mind is functioning
complex machinery
this is the most sophisticated machine
in this planet is human body and mind
isn't it
everything that we have created has come
out of this mind
so this mind is a complex Machinery very
complex
so if you do anything wrong it will
create many distractions within itself
there are certain simple ways there is
some simple technology with which you
can keep your mind in a certain
condition of clarity where it simply
sees that you learn to keep your mind
like a mirror it simply shows you what
is there it doesn't distort
the moment your mind gets identified
with many things now you are playing as
an Indian hockey player now you get all
this started because now you're reading
the whole history the glory of Indian
hockey the depths of Indian hockey
everything will flow in your mind now
you will not play the game you will not
see the game the way it is first of all
learning to keep the mind like a mirror
where it simply shows you what is there
in front of you without any distortion
once there is no Distortion you will
walk to the best of your ability isn't
it
now you're walking on this floor there
is no Distortion in Your Vision you can
see everything clearly
to the best of your ability you will go
isn't it in your very Vision if there is
distortion
you will unnecessarily stumble all over
the place
so whatever talent you have whatever
capability you have if it has to find
full expression your mind doesn't come
in between and distort anything it just
shows you everything the way it is
so the whole yogic system is focused on
this for a spiritual purpose which can
also be used for the sport that it shows
you everything just the way it is not
some other way not the way you think it
is this is another concept which is made
its around in the world that something
else should motivate you to do what
you're doing
if what you're doing is significant
enough you don't need any other thing to
motivate you
what you're doing is truly significant
to life why do you need another
motivation to make that happen if you
really understand and experience that
what you are doing is truly important
for every life around you you don't need
a motivation life just goes on see
does your heartbeat need a motivation to
keep it going
I'm asking you
all the life processes is not asking for
any motivation isn't it monsoon's coming
any motivation no it's coming year after
year because the natural process is
going on simply like that in you and me
life is on
what I'm telling you is if you're doing
something which is aligned with the
fundamental life process of Who You Are
this can find a million Expressions it
need not be just spiritual teaching it
can find the million Expressions that
what you're doing is aligned with your
fundamental life process then you will
not need anything to motivate you
simply as a part of life it will just
happen
how much you do simply depends on how
much time you invested on upgrading
yourself
the problem with the world right now is
people are always trying to upgrade
their activity if you upgrade your
activity without upgrading yourself you
are bound to break up somewhere it's
like
you went on a Formula One Track because
you want to be on a fast track
and you went with your maruti 800
suppose you hit the right kind of speed
all the four wheels will go in four
different directions
it won't hold up
if you want to be in that kind of speed
and that kind of track you must prepare
the machine upgradation of this one is
important if you upgrade yourself
activity will simply happen
uh many people around me
you know many times think I am
superhuman because of the activity that
I perform
this is not about being superhuman if
you explore the possibilities of Being
Human if you explore the possibilities
of the immensity of Being Human you will
realize
you don't have to be a superhuman Being
Human itself is super
so you will not need any external drive
or some other inspiration the very
process of life will do it
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there if you're stupid you can do
whatever you want
hahaha
you need to understand trust does not
mean
somebody has to behave the way you
expect them to behave
trust means whatever they do it's all
right with you
if you come to suggest it otherwise
don't do such a big word as Trust
trust means they must do what you expect
them to do
this is a certain imprisonment your
trust
trust should Empower people trust should
not limit people isn't it
so your idea of trust is to hold them
in the way you want them to be
so you trust betrayal this that works
don't get into all this nonsense
just use your sense see this is the
biggest mistake they have made they
always told you
to be good
once you are good you have all these
expectations from everybody else see
first of all they told you God is good
God is compassion God is love God is so
many things
leave what other people have told you
let's say you know nothing of this
nonsense from anybody you paid attention
to Creation you looked at a flower
carefully
one thing you can see is whatever
created this is of tremendous
intelligence isn't it
yes or no
not necessarily something as pleasant as
a flower you pay an attention to an ant
that's crawling around the way it's made
incredible intelligence or no
yes or no but nobody told you God is
intelligence
if they had told you God is intelligence
we would have had a more sensible world
so
don't don't get into all this trust
business
handle your life and relationship
sensibly
because these things will create
expectations which no human being can
fulfill
and simply struggles will happen endless
struggles will happen
trust means I trust somebody means
whatever they're doing I trust them
no I trust them means they must do only
what I expect them to do this is not
trust this is a soft imprisonment
you know
in it's still not come to India maybe
but everywhere else they got they got
colors for the dog electronic callers
no more chains the dog will be right
there it will never leave the boundary
because if it crosses that boundary
there will be a shock
okay and in America it's become very
common it runs around only in your
garden it won't run anywhere no offense
no chain
but the dog cannot run out because if it
steps out
why why are you making faces it's called
lakshman Rekha in India
foreign
[Applause]
so that's what she's talking about in
the name of trust if you cross it there
will be trouble
don't don't get into this dog tag kind
of trust
if you really trust somebody whatever
they do they may be doing it in their
own understanding of life
everybody is working according to his
intelligence and his understanding isn't
it
yes
right now probably that's all they're
capable of
if you can evolve them to another place
fantastic
if you cannot then you must see what to
do
but do not bring in such words of trust
trust should not become a way of
capturing people trust should be a way
of liberating people isn't it only those
who are not so successful are those who
are not successful think somewhere if
you read 10 points in a book you're
going to be successful those who are
successful they know they stand on their
head and do circus on a daily basis
okay only in the parties they stand up
straight rest of the time they are on
their head
s okay
we need to understand this if you want
to be successful don't seek success
what you seek is competence
if you enable yourself and if you do
something well other people will say
you're a success if you think I'm a
success it's foolish isn't it
you're doing something and you're doing
it well
other people in the town are in the
country or in the world people will say
oh he's doing something really
successful
they're looking up to you that's fine
you look up to yourself with madness
Okay
okay you don't seek success you seek
empowerment you seek competence you do
the best that you can do
you cannot do as well as somebody but
you can do the best that you can do
so if you do your best if your best is
good enough world will recognize if it
is not you will be happy
this body is a a huge body of memory
evolutionary genetic karmic articulate
inarticulate unconscious subconscious
conscious levels of memories you can
bifurcate into many many more strands
but essentially what you know as myself
is just a consequence of the memory that
is stored within you which is largely
not in your excess but it is playing out
in its own way the very way you sit and
stand the way you look the way you
behave everything is controlled by your
memory or in other words in modern terms
let's say this is an unconscious
software that you have gathered within
yourself
whichever way the software is that is
the way the machine will function
if you want to go beyond this then the
existing software you must leave and
either rewrite your software or learn to
operate without software for a little
while if you want to rewrite your
software something different from the
existing data which is already there
then you need access to another
dimension of perception and knowing
having said that within us there are
different dimensions of intelligence
well in yoga we see 16 parts to human
mind but let me make it four for the
sake of understanding and convincing the
first one is the intellect which is the
front end of our intelligence because
this is very necessary for our survival
if we don't have a functioning intellect
we will not know how to survive
when I say functioning intellect
essentially intellect is discriminatory
in nature it tells you what is what what
is this what is that
if you do not if you don't have an
intellect functioning you will not know
whether to go through the wall or go
through the door that's how it will
become it is functioning all the time it
is this functioning is happening from
memory if say a child may try to scratch
the you you will see a bird or an insect
comes into the house he doesn't know how
to get out he doesn't he doesn't
recognize the door it tries to go
through the wall it tries to go through
the glass window so that is happening
because in its memory it's not there but
your pet dog or your pet bird knows how
to go through the door or the window
whatever is open so this is the same
thing without data your intellect cannot
function so anything that functions with
data is a limited possibility
that it is functioning within those
limitations memory is hugely empowering
on one level but it is also a boundary
that now I have seen you
if I see you again oh this is my friend
with Sam okay
suppose you are not in my memory I look
at you and think oh who is this stranger
so memory is also a boundary line which
most people refuse to cross so whether
you read one or ten or thousand books
you are only building memory if you
operate within this memory you are
operating within your own self uh you
know self imprisonment that you have
caused to yourself when you're talking
to other people about them focusing
Inward and and training that muscle
right because even as a five-year-old
you could stare at something
and ask questions like that's a that
level of focus
is something that is either you're born
with or you have to learn it's
everyone's capable but some people kind
of have it easier than others when it
comes to focus this whole moment is
called as inner engineering
when we say engineering see right now
you have some engineering going on here
the wiring it's engineering electrical
and electronic engineering there's a
building here it's civil engineering
how well this machine works
determines how well engineered it is yes
if something is working really well for
you then only you say it is well
engineered
is it not important to understand that
the most sophisticated machine that you
operate in your life is a human
mechanism itself your own body mind and
the complex mechanism that it is on this
planet this is the most sophisticated
and complex complex machine on the
planet there isn't anything better than
this here
so I'm asking you have you read the
users menu
right
then if you don't read the user's manual
you just somehow if you if the guy who's
playing the sound there if he doesn't
know anything about that machine if he
just bangs it here and there once in a
way it works right now once in a way
people are happy once in a way there is
a sparkle of Genius no there is a way to
engineer yourself that every moment you
Sparkle every moment you blissed out
there is a way to do this because this
machine is something that you need to
take charge of but today your education
systems your social structure is such
right from the day you are born they're
teaching you how to conquer the world
but nobody is telling you how to take
charge of this the quality of your life
will not depend on what you conquer in
the world even if I give you the whole
planet you could still be miserable all
right but if you take charge of this one
you determine the nature of your
experience if you determine the nature
of your experience what would you choose
misery or blissfulness
see right now if you
instead of philosophizing reading
scriptures reading self-help books all
this just pay attention to the trees
around here
what are they doing
being be no no no no no they have no
capability to be
they're not called beings only you call
being human being you are they are not
that's just a tree it's a wonderful tree
what is it doing beneath the ground it's
fighting all right what is it fighting
for
is this
maple tree trying to produce apples no
no it is just trying to be the best
possible maple tree it can be
it is not trying to produce apples
definitely I don't see any coconuts up
there
all right right
this is all as a human being you must
see how this life can blossom into its
fullest if it blossomed to its fullest
somebody may become rich
with money for somebody may become
intelligent somebody may become
knowledgeable somebody may become loving
somebody may become an artist somebody
images Wonder
but a fully blossomed human being is a
joy to see no matter what the hell
they're doing or what they're not doing
whichever way they are an asset to hold
Humanity instead of doing that you want
for example you said abundance in
economic terms what is your idea of
abundance in economic terms Jeff Bezos
is it
me personally that's not it but you mean
having enough to be able to do what you
want not feeling like you're a slave to
paying your business I'm not insulting
anybody I'm just saying right now yeah
everybody's saying in the world or
whatever so what is your idea of
abundance 200 billion dollars of
personal wealth
I'm asking are you up to it
the 200 billion for me yeah yeah why not
uh that's not my definition of abundance
but that is what is it
[Music]
um
probably I mean probably over
I guess it depends on what age I am
yeah
10 years old is like a hundred thousand
dollars I'm rich you know uh my present
I mean I feel pretty abundant
financially but I mean
if you're asking for a specific number
no no I'm asking for a number not
because I want to find out your number
yeah I'm asking because these numbers
are bloody meaningless they're all
socially relevant not relevant to you
and anyway talking about Karma right now
let's say you are the guy who has 200
billion dollars yes it's only in your
memory if I erase your memory your money
is gone hello yeah
it's gone isn't it well it's like a bank
account it is in that account but if you
if you've forgotten what yeah if you
forgot the code or you've got any access
then a whole lot of people buried their
treasure all over the bloody world right
and somebody else found it thousand
years later that's true a lot of people
have lost all their Bitcoin and they
can't get access to it yeah yeah so all
these issues are there but the important
thing is why do you want affluence let
me put the word abundances okay an
individual person wants affluence
a society wants affluence a nation wants
affluence everybody is striving for that
why
because initially it means a choice of
nourishment
a choice of nourishment yes if you have
money you can eat what you want
initially that's the goal yes
if it goes beyond that after you eat
everything you want to eat next thing is
a choice of Lifestyle yes
now for example United States of America
has the highest choice of nourishment
choices highest level of nourishment
choices highest level of lifestyle
choices all right
that you're spending 3.25 trillion on
health care right oh wonderful that's
big that is larger than India's economy
really for 1.4 billion people we don't
have a three point three and a quarter
trillion dollar economy all right
so what is the abundance you're seeking
you you want to destroy the planet
that's what you're saying
how do I say for me I'd say for people
who actually yeah no no I'm saying this
the thing that you're thinking is
because you're in California your idea
of abundance is here
if you are in Timbuktu right your idea
of abundance would be this right all
right of course so I'm saying do not
think in terms of abundance
think in terms of a fulfillment of Life
yeah if you are a fulfilled life
according to your competence according
to your capability according to the
times in which you live you will do the
appropriate thing
human attention
has
shifted to many things that we could do
that we are not able to do right now
but one large area
which has been left and explored
is uh the human being itself
whatever kind of Technologies we develop
whatever kind of machines we build
essentially
we can only
think of doing something which is an
extension of our existing faculties
see if you were made like a tree that is
rooted to one place
would you have
thought of a bicycle
hello
only because you already have Mobility
you thought about enhanced Mobility
that evolved into many things
only because we can speak
we came up with a microphone and a
telephone
if we had no such thing as speech
would we have thought of a microphone on
a telephone
because we can see
we have microscopes and telescopes
every machine and every Gadget we create
is only enhancement of existing human
faculty
we can see this for but we want to see
that form
we can speak this for now we want to
speak that far
we can hear this for now we want to hear
from somewhere else
everything
there is no other way for a human brain
or human intelligence to function
we will only
think of how to enhance this
the purpose of enhancement
is essentially
a longing to enhance the quality
the content
and the profoundness of our life
if you are very clear that what you are
doing is significant
[Applause]
for every life around you
other people's opinion means nothing I'm
saying for 30 years plus they've been
saying the same things they are not even
creative they're not able to come up
with anything new
all right same thing they are saying
but they've not gotten anywhere because
they have no substance
there's no substantially anything that
they have said
so
it's unfortunate
that they are in that state
but what I see is every daily Mystic
court is there you know daily quote
all these people are just waiting
one thing that they don't understand
suddenly all of them will get together
and make it make their Twitter trend
I'm so glad
because every day they're reading my
quotes even people who are here are not
reading
[Laughter]
okay
I'm saying every day carefully they're
reading my code the day they don't
understand they think I made a mistake
and boom they'll go
I'm glad
I've worked in prisons both in India and
United States I worked with hardcore
criminals
who have come for murder rape worst
possible things that a man can do for
those things they have come and I've
seen significant transformation with in
their lives simply because of two days
or five days of contact with me these
guys were continuously following me I am
very confident one day they will be very
transformed I wish them the best what
does success look like
what does it take well uh
you know I know
family and friends
who always have their breakfast on time
and after breakfast of course they must
have coffee
after coffee of course they must light
up a cigarette
and sit there nicely because they're
trying to
become peaceful
and then they will go to work
come back home exactly on time for lunch
eat lunch
rest for one or two hours sleep
then evening have on tea and then smoke
and then again go to work
and eight eight o'clock 8 30 they're
back home for dinner and then maybe
other things drink and this and that and
whatever
but those
who have been very successful either in
music sport art business spiritual
process doesn't matter what
those people
never know when they hate when they
slept when they got afternoon rest I've
not seen such a thing in my life
[Music]
so uh
those who are committed to being
successful with whatever they are doing
one important aspect of their life is
they're not settling down wherever it's
a bit comfortable
because Comfort will happen
when they lower you in the grave very
comfortable you are
right now it's about ensuring
that there is profoundness of experience
and there is impactfulness of activity
because
if they had given you a limitless amount
of time
you could do all those things nothing
wrong I am not against them
but they gave you such a little time
with such tremendous potential of Being
Human that's the problem
how would you explain Karma to someone
who grew up in an Eastern culture where
Karma takes on a completely different
meaning and is used for control and for
right and wrong no I would say uh using
Karma as an instrument of creating fear
or guilt is a western instrument not an
Eastern one you aren't by the time your
aunt came into the world there was too
much Western influence in the country
above all in many ways being ruled by
the British for 20 you know 25 decades
we somehow assume they're Superior to us
we are still trying to shed it many of
us still not been out of it so because
of that we took to those things where
the entire Society is only based on
guilt and fear the whole religious
structures of the world unfortunately
based on fear and guilt without fear and
guilt there is no nothing without reward
and Punishment there is no nothing this
fundamentally drips down from the
fundamental idea of heaven and hell if
you are good God will send you to heaven
if you are bad he will send you to hell
and burn you there forever whatever not
just for a few days forever okay
if you're burning forever maybe it'll be
okay I'm saying only if you're outside
and going to fire is very painful if
you're burning all the time I don't
think it'll be a problem you'll get used
to the temperature like right now we
have a certain body temperature we
gotten used to it all right
maybe your body temperature will be 300
degrees Centigrade but
it should be okay we must understand
however individual people might have
tried to use it
karma is not about control
karma is about Liberation only when you
talk about mukti we talk about Karma
we don't talk about Karma about heaven
and health
Karma means my action my responsibility
my life is my making so if you
understand this you will not be
controlled from outside you will be
liberated from inside in the sense
see
it's like this
the whether let us say people are eating
drinking smoking whatever they are doing
you can do those things or not do those
things because you're controlling
yourself because it's a bad thing to do
or you can make yourself in such a way
that you're feeling so fantastic you
don't need to do those things
so one way you're controlling it another
way is you're liberated if you're
controlling it you will do all kinds of
free other freaky things this happen one
day if you can if you can mind well you
can take a joke I'm sure hello yes we
want everybody for 100 days I'm riding
30 000 kilometers these 100 days I want
all of you to talk about soil in your
own capacity whatever information that
you need we are providing a massive
amount of information because all the
top scientists of FAO world food program
unccd unep are you see and they're all
with us and the top scientists are there
every information that you want we will
provide otherwise you can always
research your own this thing but the
most important thing is everybody
everybody who listens to you and all of
you say something about soil for 100
days and let's change the narrative
because without people speaking up in a
democracy governments will not take any
step the reason why this has not
happened and nobody is addressing this
ease our democratically elected
governments last for four to five years
that's their life you know that's their
term rather
why would they want to invest in
something which takes 15 years 20 years
to produce results unless people ask for
it so this is just an effort to move
three to four billion people across the
world that they speak if they don't know
anything else just say save soil let us
make it happen right that much at least
if 100 Days A lot of people three to
four billion people speak on this we
have a way of aggregating these numbers
with social media platforms and using
this we will bring about us policy
change I am addressing the cop 15 in
Ivory Coast in the month of May where
170 nations are there before that we
want to have substantial numbers so that
nobody can ignore it in a democracy the
only currency that flies is numbers
so we will move safe soil to the top
right now we had drink water and take
naps we've been just trying to get
people to take naps and drink water
that's really what we've been on for a
long time but safe soil safe soils and
then drink water take a nap where are
you on uh removing animal products from
the diet
see right now uh the important thing is
if
the if the vegetables that you eat the
vegetarian diets that you eat especially
in this country I would say especially
in this country not because this is the
only place this is happening probably
this is the only place where there's
enough studies to show that the
vegetables that you ate in early 20th
century let's say in 1920 you ate
something let's say a piece of lettuce
or a carrot what it had to offer for you
today it has only 10 percent of that
nourishment 90 is gone that's right if
you ate one Orange today you have to eat
eight oranges to get the same stuff so
naturally people shift to meat so it's
important that soil organic content goes
up the Vegeta the the vegetables that
you eat the vegetarian food that you
would eat has much higher level of
nourishment then the other thing will
naturally go down because already there
is a momentum towards eating more
veggies and stuff in the country which
was not there just 20 30 years ago so
that moment is anywhere there but the
important thing is to make sure that
vegetarian diets have the necessary
nourishment that can only be done by
enhancing the organic content in the
soil
why am I afraid
I'm successful and you know I had some
hard times but I came back but why am I
afraid what am I afraid for like I'm
just afraid that somebody might think
I'm a wood CEO or a wimp or something
why am I so afraid of that
when they don't understand this
this has been usually
misinterpreted and
misunderstood
on various dimensions
whether it's fear
or love
oranga or joy
we need to understand it's not about
something
it's by itself
it is not that there must be something
that you must be afraid of
it is not that
there must be somebody that you are in
love with
it is not that
you're happy about something
or miserable about something
you can be simply miserable
hello thanks
or you can be simply happy
you can simply sit here just by yourself
and be very loving
you can sit here and be terrified about
nothing
because
Human Experience is not created from
outside
Human Experience is happening from
within
so what happens from within
May sometimes find Outside stimulus
but you can work it even without
external stimulus
hello all of your experts
without any external stimulus you can
create Spain you can create Joy you can
create misery you can create anger love
fear whatever you want
because the seat of experiences within
you
only thing is you are not sitting there
you're crawling around it
you're supposed to be sitting there on
the seat
if you are sitting on the seat of your
experience
you decide what should be the nature of
your experience
right now because you're crawling around
something happens accidentally we find
an excuse
it's because of this guy I'm so
even if he's not there we would find
somebody else
hello
if that guy is not there we'll find
somebody else if that is not then we'll
find something else
so this is not about something
this is about
that you have not taken charge of the
seat of your experience that's all
you just need an excuse and world will
of course
the world is quite enthusiastic about
providing you the excuses
it will
they will provide lots of excuses
but believe me if you are alone in the
desert you would still go through all
these things without anybody around you
without any threat to your life yes or
no
so
this is the fundamental flaw with life
[Music]
instead of fixing myself I want to fix
the whole world
well do what you want
you can't even fix one more person
absolutely in your life
100 did you get anybody ever just the
way you want 100 if at all if you're
looking for that kind of success 100 you
can only try with this guy try anybody
else you will find
yes or no
try anybody
you will definitely fail
there's only one
this one you could do him hundred
percent the way you want
if you manage this one the way you want
where is the question of fear suffering
Misery all this
this is not because of situations
this is because of the state we are in
because no investment has been made
for the being the two kinds of people
some people are interested in talking
some people are interested in listening
you must decide which is wiser
some people are interested in expression
some people are interested in perception
it is perception which enhances your
life
not expression everybody is busy
expressing their Madness in the world
everybody is busy expressing their
limitations in the world
prejudices and opinions in the world
what is the use of this expression I'm
saying
birds are tweeting it's a little more
pleasant than all these human beings
tweeting
expression is like an expanse of life
expanding it
perception is enhancement of life
this life for you should be about
enhancing it not about expanding it
I want you to look at it
at this moment in your life
just sit back and simply look at it all
the things that have found expression
from you
[Music]
take away the social context just look
at it as life
you're born one day and you'll be dead
one day in between this all the things
that you've said and done and expressed
what meaning does it have
[Music]
but what value is it to life either to
your life or anybody's life okay this
moment I can say something and impress
somebody here maybe I can teach
something to a child and
you know help him to
learn something live better whatever
but in terms of existential Life as a
piece of Life what does it mean all the
things that I've expressed
it means nothing but all that you have
perceived
will make this go life go far
if you want to find expression to what
literally you have perceived already
I would say wait
this restlessness is you know across the
world now it used to be an American
phenomena but now it's everywhere
everybody is restless before they are 20
they want their life to be done
everything that you can do in your life
should be done because there is a
restlessness
of wanting to be who fear that you may
not find expression
there is no need to be afraid of finding
expression because
if you become profound with your
perception
your expression happens not verbally not
by action
it becomes akashic expression they are
the only ones who live
today in my experience
if I simply sit here
for me
whether it is Yogi or Krishna or Buddha
or anybody any of the yogis who lived
beyond their physical nature they are
all present for me here they're alive
here
they are not past when I speak about
them I talk about them they're like here
because they are here
if you do action with your physical self
it leaves a certain wake in the
existence and it obliterates itself
if you do something powerfully with your
mind it leaves a larger wake but it will
obliterate itself after some time if you
reverberate your physical energy in a
certain way
it will leave a larger much larger wake
which has a much longer lifespan and it
dies
but if you do something beyond that
if you do something with your
fundamental Consciousness then the Wake
that you leave is forever
when the planet goes away you know the
solar system has its lifespan when it
implodes into itself or explodes
whichever way it goes
even when the planet goes away
what certain people have left will not
go
you've heard of markandai
Mark and I lived through the destruction
of the solar system and again came back
because what you do with your
Consciousness does not die when the
physical dies when I say the physical
dying not about an individual dying even
when the solar system dies when the
universe dies when the whole galaxy dies
what you did on the level of your
Consciousness will not die it leaves
awake forever and always available to
humanity to any being of any nature who
has the necessary perception for that
being it'll always be available
so do not focus your life on expression
it'll go waste
perception
let this life be a lifetime of
perception can you give us two tips that
you think that we could live through our
big as an example to others
see when we use the word Peak
naturally you want to go mountain
climbing
that means you want to do something
others cannot do
not necessary because
the peak is not in what you're doing
outside the peak is in the way you
experience it isn't it
somebody can do something very small
with very profound experience
somebody can be doing big things without
any sensitivity to what's happening
around them
so essentially
what you're looking for just look at
this as yourself as a life right now you
become so many social entities you may
be lost in that but actually you're
alive most people realize they're alive
only when they're threatened with death
till then there's something else
they become so many other things no no
no matter what work you're doing here
you're just a piece of life isn't it
it is a fortune that certain things
happen through us which will impact many
other lives wonderful but still this is
a life only if this life functions in
its best possible way everything else
will happen
best possible way means what
is this very clear that uh you are not
taking your your own apartment when you
go I mean when you when you die and
leave you're not taking
they tell me you're creating very nice
apartments and you're not going to take
it right your own accommodations you
can't carry you know that
so obviously the only thing that is left
here is the profoundness of your
experience isn't it
how profound is your experience to make
our life profound somebody says if you
have education you can do this well
everybody went to the university I
didn't
somebody said if you have money you can
do it everybody ran after it
somebody said if you can get married
it'll happen everybody got married
somebody said if you have children then
it will happen everybody did that
somebody said this is not it you must
get power in the world so people ran
after that essentially what should
happen inside you're trying to cause
from outside
hmm what should actually happen within
you you're trying to cause it from
outside yes it is possible sometimes it
can be stimulated from outside but
it has to happen within you all Human
Experience comes from within you is that
so
your joy and misery pain and pleasure
anything and anything Agony and ecstasy
can only happen from within you
the question is only your joy your peace
your love your ecstasy is it on push
start or is it on self-start I'm talking
about upgrading Technologies
there was a time in 1950s or 19 yeah
1950s if you bought a car
you needed two people to help you in the
morning because it's a push start
if you got one in early 60s it's a crank
start you need one person to help
today all our cars are self-start right
technological upgradation
things which are most vital to you the
profoundness of your experience
the pleasantness of your experience here
but right now it's all on push start if
you have to be happy how many people we
have to fix in this world
if you
if you have to be peaceful we have to
fix the entire world
so there is an endless amount of
conditions
for your experience to be in a certain
way
and in pursuit of human well-being we've
turned the world upside down we've
ripped the planet apart but still
we are not a we are not the most joyful
generation we are definitely the most
comfortable generation ever never before
another generation of people have
enjoyed these kind of conveniences and
Comforts as you and me are enjoying
right now isn't it so never before but
can we say with all these Comforts we
are the most joyful generation
no not true I am not saying we are more
miserable but definitely we are not the
most joyful
are we peaceful no are we loving no
so our experience of life is still like
how the caveman's experience was same
anxiety that guy was worried where's my
food you are worried where is my next
apartment
endlessly you think it's different it's
not different it's rudimentary isn't it
hello the idea of organizing our
survival process the way we have
organized is we need not be concerned
about it isn't it so hello
you open the tap water comes don't think
it's small it's a small thing just 100
years ago water means you have to go to
the river
with a pot on your head
so today all this convenience that we
did why because we don't have to concern
ourselves with daily survival everything
is organized now we believed if all
these things are organized we will sit
here blissed out well that's not
happened
it's not happened simply because we have
not taken charge of this so peak of
human life does not mean you climbed
Mount Everest
I have gone up Everest you know that
no you didn't know
yeah very top
Somebody went up there and took a
photograph with my picture in his hand
so I believe I've been there
website
because this guy who went there took a
picture with my picture in his hands
came down and said Guru of of 12 people
that we started out only two of us made
it to the top and I took the picture and
I came down
we were there just about 40 seconds
right on the top because winds were
picking up speed we had to come down
only 40 seconds I looked around and I
couldn't see a thing
and I came down now I'm wondering why
did I do it
because you wanted to know the peak of
suffering
it's not a simple physical challenge
climbing Everest is not a simple
physical challenge I'm not saying you
should not climb all I'm saying is the
peak can only happen within you it will
not happen outside of you
so if the peak and the valley and the
very bottom can only happen within you
people can sit in a palace and be
depressed
like they're at the pit of their life
isn't it so
hello
so similarly if that is possible you can
sit on the street and be on the peak see
there are only two sorts of people who
are very clear about everything in their
lives
a fool and a fanatic
so if you're confused you're neither of
these two which is a good sign
utter idiots and Fanatics are always
dead sure of everything
they know they're going to heaven
only their only problem is they want to
take you along
they need company
there's a thing going everywhere
particularly in the western world but
it's very much come to Urban India in a
big way today
that is uh you want to be decisive this
is it
see
I'm reconsidering my life all the time
all the time whether I should continue a
satguru or should I become a Chef or
should I just go back to motorcycling or
should I do something else or should I
play golf should I do something
or should I simply lace around why not
I'm always considering
every day
and still I'm making a decision it's
better to do this
yes I am not decided
I'm still considering
and that's why it's valuable
not because I decided long time ago I
have no choice I keep on doing the same
thing because I'm stuck in this the
nature of the mind is
it is intelligent and Alive only if
every moment it's looking
if it is concluded and decided it is a
dumb mind he says go to the block of
wood
every moment it's considering
only then it is an active mind
it's only that
you make this choice you make you must
be joyfully confused that's all I'm
saying
people get confused and miserable
because they have an idea that they must
be
they think all successful people are all
clear and they determined they've made
their decisions
no only Fanatics are like that
and fools are like that
somebody who's successful he's keeping
his eyes open for anything and
everything right
so uh this idea that your mind must be
made up
he's a silly idea
it's important that every moment it's a
choice everything that you're doing life
becomes beautiful
because there is enormous Joy because
you want to do this right now
because I decided 10 years ago I'm doing
it
how will you have any joy in what you're
doing right now so this every day in the
morning you get up and you don't know
what to do it's a perfect way to get up
yes
this does not mean that you will do
different things every day even if you
do the same thing it's by choice
then it keeps you alive to everything
that you're doing because you're doing
it by choice
the choice that you're making is now you
might have made the choice same Choice
ten thousand times in the last 10 years
it doesn't matter but now you're once
again making an active choice this is
very important
only then you will stay alive to life
otherwise I made my choice it will
become a burden
I made my choice long time ago so I have
to do it now is a very burdensome
process to live with
so confusion
is way better than silly conclusions
that people are making about life
only thing is you have to learn to enjoy
the confusion
yes I'm working hard to make you
confused
yes
because all kinds of idiotic conclusions
about life
all kinds of stupid conclusions
say for a long time people had this
conclusion
that they will go to heaven all right
I'm just taking one
Troublesome thing right now because
with Afghanistan as a situation it's
troubling everybody in the world
heaven-bound people what they do on this
planet is
because they are going to heaven what is
on this planet is not a value
anyway they're going to happen
so now they brought it to everybody's
face it's always so it's just that
people don't see it most of the time but
now with a geopolitical situation they
are rubbing it on your face
we are going to heaven you are not going
so you see what we will do to you
anyway I'm not going to your heaven I'm
not going to compete with you in the
real estate of Heaven you can leave me
alone hello yeah I'm not going to heaven
so you are heaven-bound people you
should ignore me isn't it
but no you cannot because your life will
not fly if I live
your life will fly only if you get rid
of me isn't it
so these things are happening because
people have conclusions how they arrived
at this conclusion who helped them to
make these conclusions I am taking a
very
esoteric conclusion but in daily life
also this is happening somebody believes
this is right
just this one stupid conclusion how many
parents have tortured their children
hello
they love them but they torture them
they smash them up every day yes or no
they love them they hold them as a light
of their life but everyday daily torture
because they think this is the way that
is the way
why can't you look at it every moment
and see what brings maximum well-being
to this and to everything else why can't
we look what is the problem so if you
don't know how to make these choices if
they're confusing you the problem is
there is no love or commitment towards
anything
okay
if there is an immense sense of Love
towards something all these things will
fall into place
see you don't need morality you don't
need values you don't need ethics if
you're conscious you don't need any of
those things suppose that is not
possible the next best thing is you have
a deep sense of love
if you have this you again don't need
any values you don't need any ethics you
don't need any anything because what you
love you will take care in the best
possible way
because people think I think I should
read this to you because people think
love is a sappy talk and you know I love
you you love me nonsense going on
everywhere no it's a very deep sense of
integrity and commitment isn't it
when you genuinely love something or
somebody there is an enormous sense of
Integrity towards that you will never do
anything
harmful to what you love if you
genuinely love
if love is a mutual benefit scheme
I mean it's a different matter you need
to build something if you don't have
anything then this man's possibility of
considering and reconsidering everything
every moment becomes a painful process
otherwise this becomes a fantastic
process
you have to become either conscious or
at least loving hello
once you have this then you will see
this daily consideration will not be
painful it will be very joyful and
wonderful
someone who has some faith in a God or
in a temple or whatever
who is her simple-minded Faith Works
only for those people who are
simple-minded thinking people people who
are too much thinking for them it never
works a childlike person
who has a simple faith in his God or his
Temple or whatever
he goes to the temple and says Shiva I
want a house I don't know how you must
make it for me
now in his mind there are no negative
thoughts will it happen will it not
happen is it possible is it not possible
these things are completely removed by
the simple Act of Faith
now he believes Shiva will do it for him
and it will happen
[Music]
going to come and build your house no I
want you to understand God will not lift
his little finger for you
what you refer to as God is the source
of creation
as a Creator he has done a phenomenal
job there's no question about it could
you think of a better creation than this
is it in anybody's imagination to think
anything better than what is there right
now
so as a Creator he has done his job
wonderfully well
but if you want life to happen the way
you want it because right now the very
Crux of your happiness and your
well-being is this
if at all if you're unhappy
the only and only reason why you're
unhappy is life is not happening the way
you think it should happen
that's all it is
so if life is not happening the way you
think it is it should happen you're
unhappy if life happens the way you
think it should happen you are happy
it's as simple as that
so if life has to happen the way you
think it should happen first of all
how you think
with how much Focus you think how much
stability is there in your thought and
how much reverberance is there in the
thought process will determine whether
your thought will become a reality or is
it just an empty thought
or
how you do not create any impediments
for your thought by creating negative
thought process
this possible
is something possible or not possible is
destroying Humanity
what is possible and not possible is not
your business it's Nature's business
your business is just to strive but what
you want
right now you're sitting here
if I ask you two simple questions
I want you to just look at this and
answer this
right now from where you're sitting can
you just fly off you say no
you get up and walk you'll say yes
what is the basis of this
why you say no to Flying and yes to
walking because past experience of Life
many times you've gotten up on walked
never did you fly off
or in other words you're using the past
experience of Life as a basis for
deciding whether something is possible
or not possible or in other words you
have decided that what has not happened
till now cannot happen in your life in
future
this is a disgrace to humanity and the
human spirit
what has not happened till now on this
planet can happen tomorrow human beings
are capable of making it happen tomorrow
so what is possible and what is not
possible is not your business
that is Nature's business nature will
decide that you just see what is it that
you really want and strive for that and
if your thought is created in a powerful
way without any negativity without any
negative thoughts Bringing Down the
intensity of the thought process
the first and foremost thing is
you must be clear what is it that you
really want if you do not know what you
want
the question of creating it doesn't
arise
if you look at what you really want
every human being wants is
he wants to live joyfully he wants to
live peacefully in terms of its
relationships he wants it to be loving
and affectionate or in other words all
that any human being is seeking for is
pleasantness within himself pleasantness
around him
this pleasantness if it happens in our
body we call this health and pleasure if
it happens in our mind we call this
peace and joy if it happens in our
emotion we call this love and compassion
if it happens in our energy we call this
blissfulness and ecstasy
this is all that a human being is
looking for
whether he is going to his office to
work
he wants to make money build a career
build a family he sits in the bar sits
in the temple
he is still looking for the same thing
pleasantness within Pleasant is around
if this is what we want to create I
think it's time we addressed it directly
and commit ourselves to creating it so
you want to create yourself as a
peaceful human being joyful human being
loving human being a pleasant human
being on all levels
and do you also want a world like this a
peaceful world a loving World a joyful
world
no no I want Greenery I want food when
we say a joyful world that means
everything that you want has happened
so this is all all that you're looking
for so all that you need to do is commit
yourself to creating it
to create a peaceful joyful and loving
World both for yourself and everybody
around you
every day in the morning if you start
your day with this simple thought in
your mind that today wherever I go I
will create a peaceful loving and joyful
world
if you fall down 100 times in the day
what does it matter for a committed man
there is no such thing as failure if you
fall down 100 times 100 lessons to be
learned
if you commit yourself like this to
creating what you really care for now
your mind gets organized once your mind
gets organized the way you think is the
way you feel your emotional get
organized once your thought and emotion
is organized your energies will get
organized in the same direction once
your thought emotion and energies are
organized your very body will get
organized once all these four are
organized in One Direction your ability
to create and manifest what you want is
phenomenal you are the Creator in many
ways
perception happens to you in five
different dimensions seeing hearing
smelling tasting touching this is how
you're perceiving life
this data data has gathered within you
only because this data has gathered
within you now you are able to walk on a
round Planet which spins it's not a
small thing
it is not a small thing that you are
able to walk on a spinning round ball
because all this data has gathered to
Five Senses it is not intellectual
information but it is a perceptional
information if this information is not
there you won't be able to walk actually
you will not be able to walk straight
this is what is happening for people
when some people lose their memory and
things like that suddenly they become
unstable in their body because some of
the data is gotten disconnected with
their system so this data that you
perceive is most important that's what a
child is all the time drinking up
everything you see how the child is
looking at everything because he wants
to drink up as much data as possible
because instinctively he knows without
the data he will not be able to function
so how attentive you are how attentive
your eyes are how at interview your ears
nose tongue and touch is accordingly you
have that much you know that much usable
information so why one person is more
efficient while you are an athlete why
one person is able to catch a damn ball
another person can't catch the damn
thing why is it because that level of
attention of exactly how that ball will
be behave how you can anticipate where
it will go this is not there
intellectually suppose you have a PhD in
football you think you can play football
uh if you have a PhD no I think you need
to experience it as well if you just
study it only yeah
oh that is that
you're watching exactly how a ball moves
you may not be thinking the physics of
it but you're watching it and perceiving
it because of that perception you know
something that you cannot know by
reading 100 books about it why does one
person need a
well my prescription these days eight
hours is it seven seven to eight hours
seven hours sleep okay seven hours
and why another person can do with half
of that
see one thing is
as we already went through the very
physical body that you carry is just the
food that you've eaten isn't it
you are looking at Food only as protein
vitamin mineral like this
but we're talking about a food chain
that means they're all different kinds
of lives
what we consume is another form of life
every animal consumes another form of
life this is the way the food cycle is
created
so in what condition that life is will
determine
in what condition your life is in many
ways
so you food appears in front of me if I
just look at it
people have prepared it with elaborate
care if I just look at it I say no
this lady has brought it she's a very
good cook she's very tasty
I just look at energy now
simply because it's not alive enough for
me it may be tasty but it's not alive
enough for me
if it's not alive enough I will not
consume if you're just conscious of this
one thing
you will see your sleep quota will go
down
another thing is most people are eating
at least 50 50 means hundred percent
more than what they need to eat
yes you you will do one thing as an
experiment just try this whatever you're
eating cut it down by 50 percent
if you're eating let's say uh two
kilograms of food cut it down to one
kilogram and eat variety of foods you
will see you will neither drop weight
nor will you become weak nor will you
become less energetic only thing that
will happen is your sleep quota will go
down
because you are putting so much food to
generate the same same amount of energy
you're eating more by compulsion of
liking the taste or simply by compulsion
of filling yourself up now the body has
to press process so much food to create
so much energy this extra processing is
taking a toll on the system
the amount of impurities that are there
in the food will also determine how how
much inertia you generate in the body
let's understand it this way in terms of
physical terms what sleep means is
inertia right now your Dynamic this is
life inertia said sin
when inertia goes beyond a certain point
that's death
but sleep is a certain kind of death but
it is offering you rest
so restfulness is very important
what is being restful means is
if you sit here if you are a total ease
you will see the body is naturally
restful if you have you noticed on a
particular day you are very happy on
that day you don't need much sleep or
food have you noticed this
that's all you have to do
if you remain very joyful every moment
of your life the food will come down
sleep will come down naturally
the two kinds one is infectious
this is an invasion from another
organism you're somebody's food or
somebody's habitat
so that's a different matter that they
need to be bombed out
but I feel only 25 to 30 percent of the
world's ailments today are infectious in
nature rest is all chronic
that means people are on self-help
they're busy producing their own variety
of disease I think every year people are
coming out with various variations of
disease so that doctors will be baffled
every day
so how does one Manifest this
we must understand
every cell in human body is programmed
for life and health
at the same time the same individual
cell is also programmed from death
when it's time
it will start
dismantling the system in a certain way
so programming for Life well-being
health is also there programming for
death is also there
if you in any way create a wrong message
if your messaging is wrong then some
cells start working for your death
that's all this is is in a certain way
they are working towards dismantling of
life because somehow they got that
message you're not sending out a clear
message that I want to live healthy
I want to live well
that message is not there today if
you're angry with somebody
when you're angry or resentful with
somebody
you're not doing much to them you
poisoning yourself there is substantial
medical evidence today to show you're
literally chemically poisoning yourself
so when you yourself poison yourself
what is the message that the cellular
structure in the body is supposed to get
the message goes across and even if two
percent of them believe that you want to
die because you're drinking poison
then they'll start working for that
now conflicting different types of
activities happening one set of cells
working for your well-being another set
working against you manifests itself in
many different ways this is a simplistic
way I'm putting it but
in a way this is what is happening wrong
messaging is happening every day
resentment anger fear anxiety these are
all poisons that you drink but you
expect somebody else to die life does
not work like that if you drink you die
so because we do everything in
installments today
we do death also in installments that's
called disease
[Music]
see the most important thing is to get
the individual
committed towards their health and
well-being they must be committed
that commitment is not there
I see outside the hospital health
workers training and puffing away a
cigarette how can they get somebody
committed towards their health first
thing is to have the individual
committed to towards his health and
well-being if he's committed he will
become conscious as to what to eat what
not to eat what to do what not to do if
this enters his life half the problem is
gone
then specific help for a particular
ailment that they're suffering from can
be done
the popular teachings in the world today
I don't know how popular these are in
Mumbai
but in the west these things have become
very popular
somebody's telling you'll be in the
moment
nobody's telling you just let go
everything will be okay
that means there must be somebody taking
care of your life from behind then you
can let go
someone telling you just do one thing at
a time
don't
see
he's around regressive teachings in the
sense
just to explore one or two
what can you let go tell me
they're saying just let go God will do
it
well life has not really gotten you yet
that's why you're talking this language
you're living in a fanciful world
and life really gets you
then you will know you can't let go
anything you have to manage
you let go your business today and see
what will happen or try something more
dramatic you're driving today just let
go
a lot of people seem to have
just let go and say that you are dead or
somebody else is dead
now
these popular teachings which have
unfortunately become popular as messed
up Humanity in a big way
I I faced a group of people recently in
America
where their staunch being the moment
people
I am asking you
can you be somewhere else
be somewhere else and show me please
can any of you be anywhere else other
than this moment I'm asking
can you be
can you be somewhere else then here
right now
no
then why do you need such a teaching
what they're trying to tell you is don't
think about tomorrow don't think about
us today
that will happen if you take away half
your brain
if I pull out half your brain you cannot
think about tomorrow you cannot think
about as today just be in the moment
this is all coming because people do not
even know how to sit in one place
peacefully okay
[Music]
so people are coming up with Solutions
like this
shankaran pillai
opened a pharmacy
in United States
and
one day he had something to attend to
some little chore that he has to attend
to
so he asked his teenage son please take
care of the shop just for an hour I'll
be back
so boy said no problem dad
so he went out
in an hour's time he came back
when he came back in front of the shop
there was a man hugging the land
Lamppost and his eyeballs were rolling
wildly and he was looking totally crazy
he looked at the man
whether the man is wanting to go into
the shop or is he going out of the shop
you don't know
so he looked at him and then he went
inside and he asked his son
who is that guy hugging the Lamppost
like that
is he our customer
the boy said yes Dad he's our customer
what did you give him
oh he had you whooping cough so I gave
him a box of laxatives and made him take
it right here all of them
he said what put whooping cough you gave
him laxatives why
come on dad look at him does he dare to
cough now
there are solutions and solutions
but is it really a solution that's a
question
so now because you can't sit in one
place peacefully somebody says be in the
moment don't think about the past don't
think about the future
tell me
can you call yourself a human being if
you cannot remember the past
and project into the future
will you be a full-fledged human being
I'm asking
you wanting to go back in the
evolutionary scale because you don't
know how to handle your own intelligence
this is the biggest problem with the
human being
their only problem is this you may call
it by thousand different names but the
only problem is you do not know how to
handle your own intelligence isn't it
you will see if we take away half your
brain you will be peaceful
yes or no
but I am asking is that a solution
is that a solution taking away half your
brain
so taking away your ability to look back
into the past and look out into the
future if you take away this ability
maybe you will be peaceful for but
towards what purpose
I know so many people today are going
about talking
being peaceful or peace of mind is the
ultimate goal of your life
even the so-called spiritual teachers
and leaders are going about saying peace
of mind is the ultimate goal
you tell me from your intelligence
can you enjoy your dinner tonight
if you're not peaceful if not joyful at
least peaceful you must be to enjoy the
dinner isn't it
can you enjoy driving back home if
you're not peaceful
can you enjoy the people around you if
you're not peaceful can you enjoy the
work that you do if you are not peaceful
I'm asking
if you are not able to be joyful or
ecstatic at least you must be peaceful
isn't it
so I'm asking you is it a fundamental
requirement of life or is it the
ultimate goal of life
it's the most fundamental requirement
but now people are pushing it to heaven
they're saying peace is the ultimate
goal of life such people will only rest
in peace
anything that you're deprived of
tends to become Heavenly product
today if you say peace people say Divine
peace if you say love people say Divine
love if you say Bliss people say Divine
love divine Bliss
these are all things human beings are
capable of isn't it
to be peaceful to be joyful to be loving
to be Blissful these are all human
qualities yes or no if you're willing
you can be peaceful you can be loving
you can be blissful but all these things
have been exported to heaven
so
these simple aspects have become
complicated because of all these
teachings I'm saying
it doesn't matter where the teaching
comes from
whether it comes from me or somebody
else just keep it aside
just apply your intelligence
you cannot use my intelligence okay
you can use my wisdom maybe but you
cannot use my intelligence you can only
use your intelligence
so with your intelligence experiment
if it works let's keep it
if it doesn't work discard it tomorrow
morning
no need to continue it for one more day
but
first you must decide are you looking
for Solace or are you looking for
Solutions
if you're looking for Solace just
believe something it'll work you
understand
you believe that the source of life is
in this light bulb and every day do this
it'll work
what you're doing is just inexpensive
psychiatry
yes you're trying to manage your
psychological space with something
using an anchor outside it's all right
I'm not saying it's wrong if if you need
that you can do it
but if that's not your requirement
what you want is an ultimate solution
for life then you need something else
which will not come with this kind of
popular teachings
you need a powerful force to move you
from one dimension of life to another
so when such a need comes
if such a longing comes then you must
look for spirituality otherwise
just
just do something go climb a mountain
it'll work I'm telling you you'll build
your confidence
yes
clamber Mountain swim in the ocean all
these things will build your confidence
or believe something
but towards what end what is your
requirement is something you have to see
do you have a longing for the ultimate
or are you just trying to manage your
psychological drama
that's it first distinction you have to
make
but your psychological drama can be
managed only from within you can believe
that you're using outside help but
actually you can only manage from within
because this is a ghost that you create
you can't kill it from outside
so let go of all the teachings you'll be
fine
it's wonderful
but to feel lonely is terrible because
loneliness means somewhere you have made
your individual nature so exclusive
but there is no way to feel connected
with life around you
of course in a new place you may have a
few challenges I appreciate that but the
important thing is for any given human
being
we must understand we come along
and we go
when we are here we are seeking for
other people to travel with us as
co-travelers and that need not be only
in one form or one type of relationship
or the other it can be in any number of
ways
so above all if you do not concretize
your individuality I'm this kind of a
person
I am from this nationality I am this
race I am this religion or I am this
gender and whatever else if you just
keep yourself a little open to life that
you are alive you will see there's no
room for loneliness there's too much
population how can you be lonely
it's just that
you cannot smile at this person that you
have never seen before
if I have to smile at you I must know
who you are where you come from what you
do then only I can smile at you this is
a terrible condition for a human being
why can't you just smile at anything why
can't you smile at the sky
why can't you smile at a tree Why Can't
This Man at a cloud
why can't you smile at the sun which is
trying to burn you down
just working hard doesn't do things in
the world
this is the biggest problem right from
your childhood
your parents thought you if you study
how much you how should you study
study hard
if you work how should you work work
hard
you do everything harder
if you do things hard
things won't happen
it'll become a donkey's life
just doing everything hard
nobody told you you must study in Joy
nobody told you you must work in love
they told you you must do it hard
they made their lives very difficult for
themselves
now they were inch they are ensuring
that your life becomes difficult too
why do you work hard
what are you working hard if it's hard
Give It Up
if you can do it joyfully you do it
otherwise don't do it isn't it
isn't it so
if you're going to make yourself
miserable in the process of working
what uses your work to yourself or to
anybody around you
you just sit at the Temple Gates and beg
and eat it's better somebody will throw
you one rupee to Rupee you eat out of it
at least that you do joyfully sit there
happily
eat what people throw in your home
if you are going to make it so hard for
yourself I'm sure you're making it very
hard for everybody around you isn't it
if you're going to spread misery in the
world it's better you don't do anything
if you're going to spread joy in the
world go and do as much as you can
now you work hard
just because you work hard things need
not happen and they do not happen
one day it happened
can I tell you too
shankaran pillai's old ambassador
wouldn't start
does anybody still own ambassador
no
all of you walked out of it
his old Ambassador wouldn't start
so he went home
he had a kitten at home
he brought the kitten harnessed it
to the Ambassador
he said go let's go let's go
people looked at this and said
are you crazy
can this little kitten
pull the Ambassador card
generally it takes God to move this car
what are you doing
shankaran pillai said
don't you fool yourself I have a horse
whip
you believe
you believe you can do everything hard
and it will work it will not work just
because you do it hard you must do the
right thing only then it works isn't it
if you do not do the right thing it does
not work
people who are successful are successful
not because necessarily they work hard
they just know what's the right thing to
do with their kind of job
that's why they're successful
another day
shankaran pillai
fell into the septic tank
I wanted to imagine
right up till here in filth
please imaginance
he tried to get out desperately he
couldn't
then after some time he started
screaming fire fire
neighbors heard the fire screams call
the fire brigade
the firemen came and looked everywhere
no fire oh God
then they found him in the septic tank
pulled him out
and then they asked why were you
screaming fire
if I said would you come
[Laughter]
you must do the right thing and then it
doesn't work
so just working hard will not do you
must do the right thing otherwise it
doesn't work
now how do I enhance my competence
say let's say you want to run on the
field let's say you want to run a race
you want to run 100 meters
it is not running that you have to work
on right now you have to work on your
legs and lungs and muscle and everything
isn't it so
so if you want to become a great
engineer yes definitely an Institute
like this is crucial on one level
but any number of people might have come
here and gone not all of them became
great Engineers though they might have
produced hundreds of great Engineers
still not all of them will become simply
because of their own individual
attitudes and competence and whatever
else isn't it
so whatever The Institute can do for you
it is doing one foremost thing that you
need to do is to enhance your own
physical and mental capabilities
because if you want to be a good
engineer you have you need a working
brain
just having a degree of engineering can
maybe a passport to a job
but it is not a passport to success
isn't it
so to have a working brain
which the engineering degree will not
freeze
usually lots of degrees when people
acquire degrees they freeze their brains
they think they can now they're finished
using it and now they can rest it for
the rest of their lives
it is not so
this is only to enhance your capability
this is just an organized effort a
school a college an Institute is just an
organized effort towards that because
each individual cannot craft it for
himself that is why an institution
otherwise an institution has no other
purpose it is here to just organize that
possibility of you striving to be of a
certain competence
but
that is a mass application
but as an individual your most important
thing is you as a human being you are
functioning at the fullest level if that
has to happen there are other dimensions
which one needs to explore unfortunately
though these sciences and Technologies
for inner well-being have been the
Mainstay of this culture for thousands
of years
today we are largely losing it for
various reasons because we want to
imitate somebody else we don't want to
imitate our grandfather topiwala anymore
we want to imitate
the head seller from another country
because of that we are losing those
things but we should not we have to
bring it back into our lives this is
very much a part
of the way the culture itself is
structured
that it is all about the human being
see this is the only culture which talks
about
which even an illiterate person in this
culture is aware of that you can
actually evolve to another dimension of
existence even if I go into a village
and talk to an illiterate peasant who
has not read anything who doesn't know
anything who's not heard any of this
stuff even to him if I go he will not
ask me give me a golden horse or
something he'll say Swami
he is saying he wants ultimate
liberation
where did this fellow get this nowhere
else on the planet this is possible
nowhere else on this planet is it
possible that
an illiterate person is thinking that he
can break his present dimension of
existence and go to another place
whatever that place is
so this was bred into our culture so
deep we should not lose it it was not
just the idea there are Technologies to
become free if you became free
from the process of your body and the
process of your mind if you can sit
outside of it and work it
you would work it brilliantly do you
understand
you would be able to use this body and
use this mind only when you are able to
not treat it as myself
these are powerful instruments in your
life these instruments can be employed
the way you want it only when you have
an outside access to it right now you
are a phenomenal computer but you don't
know where the keyboard is when you
can't think you scratch this spot that's
not where it is
do you see people when they cannot think
they're thinking hard they scratch here
it doesn't work like that
there are
there are proper steps that one can take
it could be offered here if everybody is
willing for that
today
the modern world is always goal oriented
in the sense
we want to win the game
whether it's life or game they're only
thinking about winning
I feel that's a big mistake
if you
you people don't win a game because they
want to win a game who doesn't want to
win everybody wants to win
people win a game because they play well
isn't it
any team wins because they play well not
because they want to win who doesn't
want to win
you know we say in yoga if you keep one
eye on the goal
you have only one night to find your way
that's not a good way to play a game
it's better at both your eyes are on the
game
the winning the cup and the accolades
are things which happen because we play
a game well
it's not because we want them it'll
happen
because we play well it happens
so it's always best that we keep our
eyes our body our mind everything
focused on just one thing that is when a
human being functions at his maximum
efficiency
there's a beautiful
incident
in our culture
when
ronacharya is teaching
Arjuna and a few other boys
archery
he asked one by one to look up at the
tree and aim and shoot at the bird that
was sitting there
a wooden bird that was kept up on the
tree
and a small dot was marked on the neck
of the bird
and ronacharya said you must aim at that
at that particular Dot and shoot
so when they just pull the string and
they're just about to shoot he asked
them to stop and ask what do you see
so they said we see the leaves we see
the tree we see the fruit we see the
bird we see so many things everybody
said this
and when arjuna's chance came
when he was ready to shoot and Rona
asked him what do you see he just said I
see only one dot
and it is one who sees only one when
one's vision is totally one point I
think that is when you get there when
everything in you gets organized in One
Direction that is when the best results
happen
and so you're playing a hockey game it's
not about winning it's not about getting
a cup back home it's not about
newspapers it's not about Fame
your whole business is just to how to
get the damn ball into the goal
every moment of being there on the field
that's all isn't it
silence does not mean
shutting your mouth silence
what is being referred to as silence
[Music]
one can become this
see if you can
articulate the same things that you are
saying with half the number of words
suddenly you will become extremely
conscious of everything
[Music]
the wind makes its own sound
as the water
[Music]
let's notice that
in fact so does the sky
well there's headless steel objects are
making their own sounds
[Music]
they're a sense of pain sounds or
pleasure
sounds of misery
sounds of joy
for everything there is a sound
and human life is very true
sounds of life
and there are sounds of death
and that even Sounds of Silence
so this complex amalgamation of sounds
different kinds of sounds
creates a different intent
different levels of compulsiveness
different levels of bondage
uh different possibilities of
entanglement
in all this
why
one chooses to become silent
silence is not a way
of denying yourself
life
[Music]
it is not even about denying yourself
articulation
[Music]
silence is about
moving from compulsiveness to
consciousness
all sounds represent
different forms and different dimensions
of compulsiveness
when one chooses to become conscious
[Music]
not me
entangled in the compulsive nature of
existence
he eventually chooses to become silent
silence does not mean
shutting your mouth silence plugging
your ears silence
you can sing its eyes
you can dance in silence
you can even speak in silence
you can even scream in silence
we pray to God
lack effort
maybe all of them
but in What proportion
so when you separate
obviously it's something that you cannot
do anything about
when you say luck again obviously it's
something that you cannot do anything
about when you say God again it's
about
so only thing that's in your hands is
effort so put your hundred percent into
your effort
what happens happens
isn't it
so don't leave proportions of your
energy and your capability to lack God
faith all these things that's not your
business if there is such a thing it
will act your business is only effort
isn't it just do that
effort
has to be incisive in the sense
it should be focused calibrated
simply if you make effort
this foolish effort isn't it
just labor is not going to get you
somewhere right kind of action the right
timing right
place all this is important isn't it
so for all these things to happen
you need perception and intelligence
so that's all you must do in your life
constantly looking for ways to enhance
your perception and your intelligence
rest will anyway happen
this is one thing that unfortunately
humanity is not doing
they are trying to become capable of
something
do not try to become capable of
just enhance your perception and
intelligence whatever comes your way
right now
let us say it's like this you know this
is happening in the world all the time
everybody wants to become a doctor
not now if 25 years ago it was so
if you want to study means first thing
is medicine if you don't get a seat
what's next
engineering
don't get a seat what
next thing next thing like this
so let's say you became a doctor
and let us say
everybody came to the yoga program and
they stopped going to your doctor
at least your visits to the doctor has
come down isn't it
has it
has it come down or no for sure it's
come down
so business will go down
it will no more be a good profession to
go into
because very few doctors are becoming
doctors because they want to become
doctors
others are becoming doctors because they
think it's lucrative
isn't it
isn't it so
most people are becoming doctors because
they think somebody's sickness is a
lucrative business
yeah
it's a very I don't want to go into
other aspects it's quite disturbing for
me
there are a few doctors who really want
to be that
they want to understand the human system
and they want to
serve in that direction that's great
suppose everybody became healthy
you don't want that isn't it
yes you don't want that
so do not
try to put up a recipe for your success
success is only when you are able to
use yourself to your full potential
it doesn't matter whether you become a
doctor or a politician or a yogi or what
the hell you become is not the thing
success means
you are living your life to your full
potential
that's what success means if that has to
happen you need perception and an active
intelligence
how do I grow my intelligence don't
worry about that right now the important
thing is to enhance your perception
if you're able to see life just the way
it is
you have the necessary intelligence to
conduct it well
if you're not able to see life the way
it is
your intelligence will work against you
most intelligent people on this planet
are generally the most miserable people
on the planet
this is simply because they have an
active intelligence but no perception of
life
so one thing one most important thing
that people have not worked at is to
enhance their perception
they are trying to broaden their mind
that's not the point
that will only make you socially
successful not truly successful if you
want to be truly successful you must be
able to see everything just the way it
is
without distortions
if you can see everything just the way
it is life becomes a play you can play
joyfully you can play it well for sure
if you can play it well
people will say you're successful you
should never think I want to be
successful
don't ever think I want to be successful
just see how to make this being in your
full-fledged being
people will say one day oh he's
successful he's a great success
you should not be aspiring for Success
it's a miserable way to structure your
life
you will simply cause pain and suffering
to yourself
and suffering to everybody because your
idea of success is sitting on top of
somebody's head isn't it
yes or no your idea of success is right
now everybody should be below you you
must be in the top this is your idea of
success this is not success this is
sickness
so do not ever think of success
just see how to make this into your
full-fledged being
this will find expression if it finds
good expression people around you will
say oh he is a great success
that's fine
people should recognize your success you
should not be thinking how to be
successful
very wrong way to approach life
hello no
so this is the nature of your intellect
right now so if you want to train this
intellect that it can stay like this for
long long periods of time that's
fantastic that will need lots of work
but your emotion is capable of like that
there have been times in your life when
you're emotionally very strong with
somebody
24 hours
only that isn't it so has it happened or
no
so you are more emotionally competent
than intellectually competent I'm just
trying to put it gently across to you
hello it's okay
ladies will say okay it's easy for them
men are struggling what
see whether you're a man or a woman this
is true for you look at it and see maybe
your love is not focused but your anger
at least is focused
that is an emotion
if you look at the temperature or the
intensity
how many moments of your life have you
known that kind of thought which is
burning hot intensity
but you've seen such emotions isn't it
hello
easier to crank up the intensity of your
emotion than to crank up the intensity
of your intellect
because that takes a lot of work
maintaining intensity of intellect takes
enormous amount of work
the problem in the spiritual path is
just this
you are focused like this
then you see your destiny starts
organizing itself in that direction then
you become like this then you become
like this then you become like this
then it starts dismantling itself
every one of you will come to an
engineering program have experienced
this at some moment that when you came
to the program suddenly it looked like
your life was on a trajectory boom
but then
you slowly distracted yourself it
dismantles itself you need to understand
when you set a trajectory you should
stay if you want to fly
if you do this this this
anyway this way all of us are going
hello
now everybody thinks they're going like
this there's no proof for that so this
there is proof
yes or no
do you have proof that you're going up
now there is proof that you will
definitely go down unless you are one of
those who can afford to be buried in
Mars
no no the planet needs you
even if you're not useful when you're
alive
when you're dead Planet likes you
yes really Mother Earth wants to get you
back
please don't deny her that
when we talk about
devotion being the way people think
devotion means going to the temple going
to church or mosque people think
devotion means religion
no no no devotion means you're
organizing
your emotion in such a way that it works
for you absolutely
there is something
beyond what you think and feel
if that has become a real thing for you
even for a moment
then you must invest your life towards
that
yes I'm trying to but Petty things Carry
Me Away
so
you're a little falling in love with
yourself
that is why either even though the taste
of the Beyond is somewhere on your
tongue you still can get entangled
because you're little becoming inflated
personality
your little love in love with yourself
is it wrong
nothing wrong
it's just called madness
because
love is an effort
love is a longing
to include
something as a part of yourself
love is a process
love is a possibility
where you you could become
larger than Who You Are
you could become more than what you are
by inclusion
now
if you value in your own self-love
now this is going against all the
popular teaching people have been
telling you first you must love yourself
before you love anybody
if you cannot love yourself how can you
love anybody
if you say I want to love myself now
you are heading towards schizophrenic
condition
now you're creating two in one
if you want to ensure that you never go
insane
the first and foremost step that you
need to take is you take away all
divisions
and you see this is an individual an
individual means he cannot be further
divided he's indivisible
you cannot divide him anymore this is
one entity you can't make it into two
if you make it into two
I love myself
now you're heading towards Madness First
Step has been taken
if life situations
cooperate you will get there quick
if life situations don't create that
situation for you you may manage within
socially accepted
levels of that Madness
so
the reason why
even if Divine touches your tongue
even if the taste of the Divine is there
on your tongue you can still get
entangled
is simply self-love
it is a sure
step
first step towards Madness
whether you are going to get there to
the Asylum status
or you will get only to the ashram
status
is subject to many things
but
this happened to your man
he wanted to enroll himself in a college
so he saw a big building and walked in
there they had registration forms he
filled up everything
he signed and when he went to the
official to give it to be enrolled in
the college
the official said but this is not a
college this is an asylum
then the man said but no I wanted to
join a college
but the official said no this is an
asylum
then the man part
but I already filled my legislation form
so what difference I will join up
not much difference
I will join the Asylum what's the big
difference
the official agreed yes not much
difference but there is one difference
what is it
here unless you show Improvement we
won't let you get out
so
ashram is just a Sanskrit word
an English word would be too insulting
because with the taste of the Divine on
your tongue
you're trying
or
you have the
necessary foolishness in you
to fall in love with something so
limited which you call as myself
that is a sure sign of Madness
that is definitely a sure sign of
Madness
if you had never tasted it
then this is all you know
that's okay
because you don't know anything better
and the taste of the Divine is still
lingering
and you're getting entangled with
something so limited as your personality
that is definitely a sign of Madness
there is no question about it
you are in such a state of Madness
you're doomed
even an astrologer
will charge you
half price
because when your destiny is so doomed
there's nothing much to predict you know
it's easy
it's very easy so there are many aspects
to this fundamentally if you keep your
life energies very exuberant
now you will see the slip quota will
naturally come down to keep it exuberant
you should not be over LED
largely in the ashram everybody young
people also eat only two meals a day 10
in the morning seven in the evening our
activity
exceeds most people's activity in the
world and we are seven days 365 days we
don't know what's a vacation because
we're enjoying what we're doing
we don't want a break
so they never go on a vacation there is
no break there's no Sunday Monday
nonsense nothing every day something is
happening endlessly
but you will see people are very
energetic healthy sleep is very little
so energetically a human being can be at
different levels why this is important
is
see what we call as life is just a
combination of two things a certain
amount of energy and a certain amount of
time
when it comes to time it is ticking away
for all of us at the same Pace plot
doesn't run slowly for me faster for you
there's no such thing
whether you are busy you are lazy or
sleeping you're doing useful things or
useless things it doesn't matter what
you do or you do not do
time is ticking away
so there's no such thing as time
management
you can manage your energy
if you raise your energy to a higher
pitch of intensity what somebody does in
10 years you may do it in one year
so if you live for 100 years it looks
like you lived for Thousand Years
simply because your energy is pitched up
this every human being can do
the whole yogic system is one dimension
of yogic system is just towards this if
you sit here even if you simply sit here
with your eyes closed you don't sit here
in a static way
you sit here in a dynamic way
you never become Static because static
is called as death
if everything becomes static that is
death if inertia really sets in that is
death so sleep in yoga is seen as death
you die every day how long do you want
to die in a day
you really must use this word for
yourself don't tell anybody I'm going to
die
for yourself how long do I want to die
in a day eight hours a day if you die
one third of your life you're dead
in 24 hours eight hours your day means
one third of your life dead another four
hours goes into eating sleeping eating
toilet bath this that where is the time
to live I'm asking
so if life is precious
the most important thing to do is keep
your energies in an exuberant way so
that
life becomes more life feels enhanced
because you cannot enhance time believe
me in the morning if you need a bucket
full of water if you had to walk a mile
to the river to get one bucket of water
and your family needed 25 buckets of
water
you would have no time to mess yourself
now you have a lot of time to mess
yourself because our survival is better
organized than ever before another thing
is most human beings do not know how to
manage their biochemistry without
physical activity
I have seen a whole lot of people
particularly teenage boys and girls
between the ages of 12 and 16 who come
to me with some severe violent problems
within themselves if you leave them like
that they may kill themselves or kill
somebody else they're in that kind of
state
many of them have even killed their
parents you know it just happened all
over the world and in 2017 when I came
to know that in India which is not so
much suicidal in that sense because
there's a huge family support and stuff
like that in spite of that in 2017 18
600 children below 18 years of age
committed suicide
out of which 7200 are below 15 years of
age
so 12 13 14 year olds
who must be bubbling with life or
wanting to take their own lives why
obviously we're doing something
fundamentally wrong with the society
isn't it yes our goals and our stupid
ideas of what is success is driving them
nuts
[Music]
because we are trying to use our
children like race horses that's
interesting
and when you say that as something to
that represent us that we've turned into
something amazing or in what way are
they like racehorses see when you
understand Life as a race
if you're in a race what's the
subjective you must reach the Finish
Line quick isn't it
yes what is the finish line of your life
death
there you have it this may not be a
conscious process but life within you is
understanding it like that when you see
you must understand this whether you are
conscious of conscious of it or not any
human being
right now if you make yourself miserable
you must understand you are sending a
message to every cell in the body that I
don't want to live
you might not have articulated it in
your head yet
but when you become miserable you notice
suddenly your body seems heavy and it's
like doesn't want to get up from this
chair
have you seen this yes when you're happy
you're willing to bounce out everything
and do everything Bend backwards if
necessary
why this is happening is the message is
gone to every cell in the body this guy
wants to die
they're all thinking okay what can we do
to help him but by then of course you
recover
so you want to die you want to live you
want to die you want to live
the body is getting confused
because you must understand this is a
very intelligent body it's taking
instructions from you
every cell in the body has enormous
sense of memory and intelligence
if you keep sending wrong messages if
they act you did
because you're sending contradictory
messages you are not dead you are half
dead
you can give it any number of exotic
names essentially you have turned your
intelligence against yourself
this is supposed to work for you but now
you turn it against yourself it's
working against you
adolescence means Springtime of life
if you're having trouble with spring I
can imagine how you'll handle your
Winters
hello
[Music]
it's a springtime of life
when everything is high energy your body
is at your at its best
if you're having trouble dealing with
that part of your life
I can imagine the rest of your life how
you will handle
this is not any one age
maybe studies are being done on specific
people but toddlers have diaper issues
other adolescence have hormonal issues
middle-aged people have crisis
voltage
soul to Pharmaceuticals
when you are young
you bought drugs off the back street
when you're older it's over the counter
[Applause]
nothing much has changed it's just
become legal everything is becoming
legal you know
hello
a lot of things which were not legal are
becoming legal isn't it
so
this is not to make a joke out of
somebody's suffering but you need to
understand what's happening
there are many many dimensions to this I
don't think I can cover all of them in
this few minutes
but to just put some perspective to you
see there are five sources of
receptivity for you from the outside
world there are five openings your
vision your hearing your smell your
taste and your touch
the simplest aspect of life is this
essentially your eyes are designed to
take 12 hours of light 12 hours of
Darkness Starlight Moonlight okay
now literally every waking moment of
your life light is penetrating
no room
sounds
just imagine suppose you lived in the
same place it is still here like this
if you stay in the ashram it's still
quiet
if you lived here
once in a way
once in a way Some Noise happened
otherwise
gently acquired little bit of insects
making noise this that that's about it
now 24 hours something is going on
Autumn bills are going on in United
States everywhere there is some machine
buzzing all the time
it's it's like you know if I travel here
for six weeks eight weeks
it becomes like boom something is going
on in any building you sit something is
going on
when I go back to ashram in India if I
sit there it's still like that
absolutely still
the impact that it has on your system is
tremendous
but this buzzing that's going on see
what's going on even here
I am
still holding my ground I don't know
without telling me they might have
already installed I said no air
conditioners in the ashram in the
Cottages why I am saying this is
you you come to a Yoga Center because
you want to
bring your system to a certain level of
stability balance because without
balance
doesn't matter what talents you have
what intelligence you have what
capabilities you have without balance
you are no good
all these things will work against you
your own intelligence will work against
you
so all the time there is sound and
vibrations going on as if that's not
enough people are wearing headphones and
all the time Dang Dang Dang Dang they
call it music but
the musician doesn't even bother to play
it it's just a machine
banging in your ears all the time
well maybe that's maybe better than
listening to people around you
maybe you think it's better than the
automobile noises that surround you
but Non-Stop
impact of sound non-stop impact of light
non-stop impact of various other inputs
this affects everybody
an adolescence means
they are malting literally from one
stage to another quickly this is the
time
when there should have been a very
stable atmosphere
most people don't have such a stable
atmosphere
one thing is because of various things
that I already mentioned
family situations are not stable parents
are also screaming
hello
yes they are
because every movie every television
show everything is showing in the house
if you're angry you must shout you must
punch the door if not somebody at least
you must punch something you must break
something this is becoming the norm
that's a way to handle
room it is examples are being said
people think that's the way to handle
your emotion no if your emotion going
out of control shut up close your eyes
and just sit on in one place huh
yes
that's a way to handle your emotion if
your emotion is going out of control
just shut your mouth close your eyes sit
down in one place don't mess with the
rest of the world
hello
[Applause]
[Music]
at least this much responsibility you
must have when you are messed up
you don't mess the world
keep it to yourself your mess that much
you must have isn't it
Now everywhere people are demonstrating
that if you are emotional you have to
kick something you have to break
something you have to throw something at
somebody or at least at the wall
so all this and tell me
Suppose there was no television and
there was no Cinema
how many times in your life would you
have witnessed somebody being shot
but now that you're watching your Cinema
on television how many shootings have
you seen
hundreds thousands probably isn't it
you think it has no impact
not only that
from the age of five all the learning
shooting shooting shooting
maybe just on the screen but
sometimes they have to come off the
screen and do the real thing
my own Vision has never failed me so I
always kept away from all scriptures
because I didn't want to clutter myself
with something or the other
the only thing
that I learned and I continue to do is
if I look at something
if I look at a person
I know they're past present and future
that is the level of attention I'm
paying to them
I don't look at like this when I look I
look at it completely with all that I
have
if you pay enough attention there is
nothing that will not yield
so I never had any reason or need
to go looking for scriptures or
something
it all it all respect and regard for
them
it is not that I am hours to it it's
just that I have not had the time it's
good
how this whole process started is
when I was very young I realized that I
just don't know anything
see
if you realize that you do not know
if it says a full-scale realization that
you do not know anything
paying attention will be natural
because you know everything
ah you know this guy you know this this
this the assumptions and assumptions and
assumptions
well I have used it in a different way
but even if you're doing business
even it's for business purposes
the only reason why
one human being seems to be
all the opportunities seems to be going
in his Direction and not other people is
simply because
he is able to see and other people are
not able to see it's not that it's not
there for others
one is able to see and others are not
able to see
so essentially a leader means that
you're able to see something
that others are not able to see
so attention without intention
simply being attempted that's what we
were trying to do in the afternoon
not paying attention to something
just practicing attention
a very heightened level of attention
where
an unfocused attention
but when you focus it on something just
about anything has to heal there is no
other way to that attention
so I always focused on enhancing and
sharpening my attention
never in retention
because what you gather is not you
essentially you know that you exist only
because you have some sense of attention
right now isn't it
suppose you fall asleep and you lose
your attention you do not even know that
you exist
so the basis of your existence itself is
attention
and this attention need not be mortgage
to anything
you just have to sharpen the attention
see if you have a knife in your hands
there is no such thing that you have to
cut only apples with this
if you have a sharp enough knife you
could cut anything that you want but the
important thing is the knife is sharp
enough
so that your attention is clean enough
not for something or the other if your
attention has become very keen if you
wish to do a certain type of activity
you can successfully do it the greatest
predicament
that a human being faces
and the greatest tragedy that human
beings are going through
and the greatest struggle that all
humans seem to be toiling with
is just this
that sensory perception gives one-sided
perception
if you see this you can't see this
if you see light you can't see Darkness
if you hear sound you can't hear silence
so life becomes
a heap of opposites her contradictions
trying to Wade their way through these
contradictions how much suffering
unbelievable
how much confusion how much struggle
if this nearly 8 billion people if you
document what kind of suffering they are
going through in one year or in one day
just one day
it's enough for eternity
all this is simply because
they have misunderstood
instruments of survival
or as instruments of knowing
you must know which is light and which
is Darkness if you want to walk through
this
you must know which is man which is
woman if you have to operate in the
world
so these differences
are very one-sided
well in many ways I have said this now
it's become a bit uh
too common for everybody to know this
because I've been speaking about this
for some time while you are sitting here
as a man or a woman but you came here
because a man and woman came together
your mother and father exists within you
you being a woman or a man is just a
surface thing but you've taken it so
seriously and you go through a whole lot
of circus just being a man or a woman
how much circus in the world
forget about light and darkness that's
more complicated
and he's the simplest damn thing but how
much struggle how much Social confusion
how many religions and scriptures have
been written about this misunderstanding
endlessly
this is just that
because
between light and darkness you think
they are two different worlds
because it looks like that the day looks
like one kind of world this planet looks
different during the day during the
night it's a completely different world
but it is not it's the same world
I think you get that point during
Twilight to some extent this is why it's
always important to wake up before the
sun comes up
because you don't have to do anything if
you just alert and looking
slowly the perception will go into you
this is why I always in yoga Brahma
mortam you should be up because Twilight
starts then
in Twilight if you're awake you perceive
that the differences that you have made
out in your mind because
of misperceptions of senses that you
have settles within you
when that happens when Karma means
action there are four types of action
physical mental emotional and energy
of all these things the energy action is
the most important one and the most
enduring one and the most liberating one
if you do it the right way
if you do it the wrong way
the energy action which is improper
can have far more impact upon one's life
than the improper physical actions
improper mental actions improper
emotional actions
so what do I mean by improper energy
actions
one thing is
unfortunately I had to witness a few
things which I
did not wish to witness
certain people trying to misuse
a little flexibility in energy
that came with certain practice of yoga
or a certain initiation especially
there are some over smart people
that when you initiate them when it's
fresh when they're bursting with energy
they want to use it for something else
they want to channelize it to impress
their neighbors or to make some money
out of it or in some way use it
what was offered to them for their
well-being they try to do something else
that can happen or
example would be
see there are there are many ways you
can perform negative action one thing is
let's say you sat here and thought that
somebody that you don't like Must Die
or you even thought how to kill them
it has a certain level of impact on you
on another level you had a thought
but not just a thought the strong
emotion now it has a much deeper impact
upon you
you acted upon this thought and emotion
and you actually perform the action
then it has a much deeper impact on you
now
you understand that if you perform these
actions there may be consequences so you
found another way you found somebody who
will do certain type of energy action
through which
the person that you don't like will die
there is an entire science like this
one Veda among the four Vedas is
dedicated to this this is called
where it's about learning to use
energies towards your benefit and other
people's detriment
you have heard of words like black magic
voodoo and
building and whatever else you call it
where people have learned to use
energies to cause harm to someone else
once you energetically try to influence
somebody
for some benefit of your own
now this will be the worst Karma because
the impact of this goes very deep into
you because you're employing your
energies to do this
this is the reason why
even to initiate you into a simple
process like sambhavi
I am asking you to take the step of
being a mother to the world so that you
never misuse this you see everybody as
yours
because enhancement of energies has to
come with a profound sense of
responsibility
enhancement of energies has to happen
with deeper dimension of inclusiveness
without inclusiveness if you use energy
this will be the worst karma karma
so
those of you who find
some dramatic changes happening in your
life
because of initiations
you must take care
you must take at most care that you
never try to use
this ability to transform to do
something else
of course some of you think you will do
a great thing by healing Somebody by
intervening in somebody's life in some
other way
no you this will be the worst type of
karma you perform because once you try
to use your Energies
and still you are capable of anger
you're capable of drawing boundaries of
what is you and what is not you what is
yours and what is not yours when these
things are still there you should never
ever try to do anything energetically
because this will be the most impactful
Karma that you will do
this is the reason why even the basic
practice of shambhavi to initiate you
you must become a mother to the world
and this is also a fantastic way to beat
your karma if every moment of your life
if you live with an inclusive emotion of
being a mother to the world
not discriminating between what what is
yours and what is not yours right now
you cannot help discriminating what is
you and what is not you but at least
what is yours and what is not yours if
you take it away
you have solved the karmic puzzle 90
percent believe me 90 percent
of all dimensions of karma you have
solved that puzzle the remaining 10
percent
I am this
respect is not something that you ever
demand in your life
please don't ever do such a vulgarity
that you demand respect
you can only earn it
not demand it the moment you demand
yes or no
so you stand One Step higher than
somebody and you demand respect
or the only stupid thing that you did is
you came here a few years earlier than
someone else and your demand that I am
Senior it must be happening in the
college also one year senior I am hey
you better respect me yeah
just one year ahead I joined the college
and now I am Senior okay
so this is an unfortunate reality that's
well established in the world
that
in the name of religion
in the name of authority in the name of
Parenthood
in many different ways
we have been trying to establish
Authority is the truth
No Authority is not the truth truth is
the only Authority
this is why Youth and Truth
truth is the only Authority
nothing else is the authority
so if I ask a question somebody freaks
see
if you ask a question somebody freaks
because they don't know the answer
suppose you go sit in an examination and
look at the question paper you don't
know a damn thing don't you freak
just like that they're freaking why
don't you understand
hello
you they gave you a question paper you
have no clue do you freak or no
so they are also freaking
so you must understand and be little
compassionate when you ask a question
somebody freaks means obviously they
don't have an answer so you must be
compassionate considerate because
they're your seniors
they came ahead of here ahead of you but
they are no better than you so they're
freaking a bit
please make way for them I'll admit what
to do they grow a little bigger than you
but at the same time there is no need
for anybody to succumb to that
it's all right there is no need to
confront people a question first of all
say a question is a tool
a question is a tool to dig little
deeper isn't it
hello
but somebody's asking a question to
prove a point that's not good
to don't ask a question to your parents
or to somebody else just to prove your
point now ask a question because it's a
genuine question
so people were asking me sadhguru what
kind of questions can we ask what can we
not ask I said even the dumbest question
you have if it means something to you it
means something to me
if it doesn't mean anything to you don't
ask such stupid things because it
doesn't mean a damn thing to me either
but if it means something to you maybe
it's a stupid question somebody thinks
it's a stupid question but it means
something to your life
it means a lot to me
so please make sure your questions are
genuine whether you ask a parent or a
political leader or a spiritual leader
it doesn't matter who the hell you ask a
question when you ask a question you
must understand the purpose of asking a
question is to expand yourself from what
you know to enter a territory where you
do not know something that's the idea of
asking a question
but you ask a question to prove them
stupid
then maybe they're getting mad
you're entering their territory now
but you have to make sure in your life
because your life is not just about your
life how you conduct your life will
determine the nature of this world isn't
it so
when you have such a responsibility you
have to ensure that truth is the only
Authority
Authority is not the truth
it doesn't matter whether it's parents
or teachers or spiritual teachers
political leaders or God himself came
down and he said something stupid
you must be able to question him that is
the nature of this culture see even when
those entities which we considered
Divine came
in India all we did is ask questions
endless questions when Shiva came
his wife Parvati freaks him with a
million questions
when Krishna came Arjuna asked thousand
questions questions and questions and
questions I must tell you this we were
trekking in Tibet
a group of people
almost from 42 different countries
so an Indian man who settled in United
States
was uh wanted to ask a question I said
you can ask questions immediately raised
his hand and he stood up he asked a
question which lasted over eight minutes
and it was going on I said Sid this is
too long a question
then I told the others because they were
all looking like this because they are
from different nations they can't
understand this question I said see this
is a very Indian question
question inside a question inside a
question
Indians are experts in this because they
have 15 000 years of culture they have
crafted questions like this
why it doesn't matter Shiva comes
Krishna comes they want to bowl a googly
to him
that's the whole intent
so I said this is an Indian question and
I try to explain to them
what is an Indian mind and why it asks
such questions
so much of culture then one Chinese lady
she said Guru I was working at the
United Nations even there only Indians
asked questions
we never ask questions only the Indians
were asking questions all the time I
said that is India
karma is never about other people it's
only about you it's only your karma you
talk about never about other people's
Karma about the loss of life
we must understand
that
this is the nature of life we are born
and we die question is only when how you
know that's how
it's guaranteed that all of us will die
whether other things will happen in our
lives or not but all of us will
definitely die for sure but
unfortunately it happens untimely for
certain people because we have an
expectation a human being means
he or she will live a certain amount of
life
so these expectations are based on our
assumptions but life has its own ways
life has many aspects
so many young people have died in the in
this pandemic unfortunately it's so many
people that I know every day 15 to 20
people that I know well many people very
dear to me are dying on a daily basis
I'm saying
so we need to understand this when we
lose somebody it is not that we should
find some explanation and write them off
you don't write them off
you value people because in some way
they contributed and enriched your life
maybe just by a word Maybe by certain
actions Maybe by a variety of other
possibilities in so many ways human
beings around you have enriched your
life
so it doesn't matter see all the people
who are alive right now may not be with
you but you cherish them similarly they
may not be with you but you just just
cherish them for who they are don't make
them the source of misery in your life
or you are only your only kind of right
now being affected by it because in some
way they were a source of joy for you
let it stay that way they must always
stay as a source of joy for you the
greatest disservice you can do to The
Departed person is you make them the
source of misery in your life do not do
that to them this they don't deserve
because if they were here they would
have been a source of joy for you for
whatever reason life decides to leave do
not try to find explanations for that
you are you are born you never asked
isn't it
and why you die don't ask it's all right
it happens we try to do our best to see
that an individual human being lives a
full-fledged life but many for many many
many people it doesn't happen it's our
business to see and do our best to see
that their liverful life but will it
always happen no
so why you are born why I am born how
did it happen don't go into these things
because all you will have is
hallucinations do not go into that the
important thing is as a human being you
valued that human being when they were
alive please value them when they're
gone with the same sense of joy and love
in your heart do not kill that just
because they are not here if somebody is
not here let's say somebody who whom you
love is not with you is in another town
another country
is it not true that you will feel much
more love and longing for them when they
are not with you
yes the same should be true even for
this person when life really isn't going
our way how do we start to Where Do We
Begin when people are so helpless
so let's understand first what is life
and what is external situations
this is life
this is society
hello
right now you want all of them to happen
your way
they're not going to happen
you want microorganisms in the world to
happen your way they're not going to
happen
hello
what is the virus thing you want all the
microorganisms to behave just the way
you want them to behave
because nearly 52 percent of your body
in terms of numbers 52 percent of your
body is actually other organisms
your genetic material is only about 48
percent
so these are all working for you so you
have no problem
one guy doesn't work for you
so you're freaking the entire world
this life
means this
because you have only experienced this
one life isn't it so
hello
have you experienced any other life
is it possible
see do one thing take your hand touch
the person who's sitting next to you
please do this an experiment
so you'll think
you think you're experiencing that
person no you're only experiencing
Sensations in your hand isn't it
hello
you cannot experience that person this
is the nature of life
your only experiencing the sensations in
your hand you do not know what's
happening in their hand you cannot
you can do some guesswork
but you can only experience what's
within you
So when you say life you must understand
you're talking about this life
life is not happening the way what do
you mean life is not happening the way
life is happening the way you want it
unless you're covered positive
you're not it so life is happening the
way you want
Society is not happening the way you
want it
economic engine is not running the way
you want it to run
so many other things in the world
what you were expecting a little
dislocated
yes it hurts a bit here and there
but
life is here is the only thing you can
experience
you cannot experience that right now you
made yourself in such a way
that
your inner experience is created by
external situations
then you have a whole Cosmos to manage
hello
now you have a whole Cosmos to manage
because your inner experience is
determined by everything that's
happening around you
well all the best
you will never know a moment of forget
about Joy blissfulness ecstasy you will
not know a moment of ease in your life
that is why
why
you know this is probably a very
sensitive subject to touch in California
that is why alcohol drugs so many other
things have become so popular simply
because people do not know how to sit at
ease
you don't have to be on the go all the
time
if life demands people ask me how are
you active like this because generally
my schedule is anywhere between 18 to 20
hours a day seven days of the week 365
days non-stop for many years it's going
on
I'm complaining and the guys clapping
about it
[Laughter]
so people keep asking how do you keep
yourself like this how do you do this
see I'm essentially lazy
it's just that
the situation in the world demands
action
left to myself I would close my eyes and
simply said
I am made like this if I close my eyes I
can sit like this till I fall dead
really I have really no need for Action
I'm not trying to keep myself busy
there's a lot to be done so you're doing
people ask me sadhguru what's your dream
what is your dream I said my dream is
the day I am unemployed that's a great
day because if I am unemployed it simply
means everybody is doing fantastic
what more do you want dream fulfilled so
action is not something that you decide
you just decide your intent
action the world will decide how much of
what
I am you know at these economic forums
and said why am I the world economic
forum
this guy in front of Business Schools in
Harvard Business School one Professor
comes oh you're that amazing tree
planter
I said no I am not a tree planter he
said no no you planted those millions of
tea yes I did but I'm not a tree planter
us then what do you do I said uh I make
people flowers
not to entries but I'm planting trees
because the goddamn trees are missing
where they should have been
where they should have been they are not
there it's like this two men were
working on the street
one man is digging pits behind him
another man is coming and closing and
closing and going
somebody else was driving by they saw
this ridiculous Activity one guy digs
the pit another guy closes the pit so
they stopped and said hey what are you
doing here why are you guys working like
this one guy digging another guy closing
they said no no
the in between guy has gone and leave
he's the tree planter
he's not there we're doing our work
so a lot of people are doing work legs
I'm doing my work
you have no work on this planet the
planet needs work if the world needs
work we will do it otherwise why should
I think this is my work
what's your mission it's a no Mission
I'm just fooling around a bit
because
you have no business
to have your own mission
life has its own mission in some way if
you can assist and serve that that's
about it what is it that you have your
own mission are you some kind of a
tyrant all missionaries are tyrants in
some way unknowingly yes those who think
they have a mission there is no Mission
what is needed you do especially when
you study in a business school and get
certain competence to manage things or
create things
you must create what is needed not
create some rubbish and push it on them
yes
yes or no
you must see how to make life better how
to solve situations which are
problematic to a whole lot of people you
must look for Solutions and solutions
for the existing situations and of
course there are experts who go on
creating new problems
so you will never be short of problems
believe me
you just have to create Solutions not go
on a mission mode
it's learned to be like God
never intervene in anything
every day in the morning
every kind of idiot will tell you what
you should do today
you just listen
just like God
marriage will work it may not work with
your profession
see uh
you're misunderstanding this
you're trying to make this into some
kind of a value system
you're trying to make it your philosophy
I will do only what works
[Music]
well you took oath I will do only what
works now you don't know what works
because what we what works will not come
with a oath
or a commandment
what works comes with constant
observation and evolution of who you are
isn't it
hello
the same things how you made them work
how clumsily you made something work 10
years ago the same thing you may be
doing it with ease today isn't it so
or you may be doing it clumsily today
you're doing it well at one time
whichever way whichever kind of
evolution has happened
so what works
is not some kind of a formula
it is an evolution of a human being to
come to what works on all levels of life
uh
uh this is like really I mean you you're
just falling out of a self-help book
no I am not a self-help book
do what works do whatever the hell you
want
what's my problem
[Music]
but what's the point of doing something
that doesn't work
hello
I'm not telling you you should do only
what works do whatever the hell you want
but
for your life because it's a limited
amount of time
what is the point doing something that
does not work isn't it
either it should work for you or it
should work for people around you if it
doesn't work for you and anybody around
you what is the point of doing that damn
thing
this happened
soldiers American soldiers were leaving
on duty
so
one of them told the other
you know Steve's wife
she read Three Musketeers and she
delivered a triple delivered triplets
you say oh my God my wife is reading
Birth of a Nation
what am I supposed to do
that's not how it works
so don't make this into some kind of an
ethic or a philosophy I will do only
what works
well just to see what works needs lot of
application even for the smallest damn
things isn't it hello
to do a smallest thing
like hitting a ball or kicking a ball
straight
you know
how much it takes
somebody who can take a ball where he
wants wow the whole world is worshiping
him
just because he kicks a damn ball
yes or no
because people understand what it takes
nobody is worship Him worshiping him
because he kicks a ball because people
can see what has gone into it
isn't it true
people can see what has gone into
to be able to kick a ball the way he is
kicking what has gone into it is life
has gone into it
so don't make philosophies and ethics
out of everything or don't tell yourself
a commandment
I will do only what works
it's a good commandment but now you
don't know what works
so
oh no
you
you need to be conscious and apply
yourself to every damn thing
if you just learn this much
that you don't decide what is important
and what is not important there's
literally no human being
who is not confronted with a thought and
an emotion like that
but they managed to brush us aside it
doesn't bother them enough
the pain of not knowing doesn't tear
them that's the whole problem
they come to terms with ignorance they
make a deal with ignorance they will
build relationships where everybody will
confirm this is the best way to live
off Comfort companionship love affection
these are all things you're seeking
I know a whole lot of people have raised
human emotions to Heavens if you say
love they say Divine love if you say Joy
they say Divine Joy if you say Bliss
they say Divine Bliss
foreign
you don't need any God's help to be
joyful loving peaceful
as a human being you endowed with these
qualities
so all those who deprived themselves of
that they either seek God or they settle
for a dog
yeah usually
because
they want a
unconditional love this is a demand
because the nature of Love is such that
it's like a flower if you don't watch it
for two minutes It'll fall
it'll wither and fall right there
either you want to
let it fall
or you have to nourish it every moment
or you have to concretize it that means
you take a picture and keep it on your
phone screen
or you institutionalize it with marriage
or this or that
so essentially
well I'm I'm not against any institution
because institutions are needed in the
world to operate otherwise there will be
chaos
that is a different thing but you cannot
institutionalize Joy or peace like right
now we think United Nations is the
institution for peace no no you cannot
institutionalize peace
you cannot institutionalize Joy you
cannot institutionalize love or anything
for that matter institutions are
functional instruments in a given
Society I have utmost respect for them
because without it people a whole lot of
people wouldn't know how to live
you need institutions there is a
government there is a democratic process
there are variety of things all right
there are quotes there are parliaments
well ninety percent of the time some
nonsense may be happening there
but still these institutions are
important because without that there
will be total chaos
so I'm not talking against institutions
but institutionalizing things that
happen within a human being
is a silly effort
in the yoga culture
first eight years or actually eight and
a half years
is considered childhood
so these are not counted though
balavastha is up to 12. it's the eight
and a half years where you're a real
child you know it from your own
experience after you're eight and a half
only your parents thought you were a
child but you were secretly many things
yes
adults think that you are a child but
you know you are not one
because your childhood in many ways ends
at eight and a half
so if you take two side solar Cycles
which is uh
24 years or little less than that
and add eight and a half years to it
will become
32 and three-fourths or something like
this
32 years in seven months or somewhere
there
exact calculations we can make but it's
nearly 33 years
so when these two cycles end
Plus
living that when it ends
it is a possibility
this is a time when your life could take
on a different level of propulsion
if you have prepared yourself well
either with education or some skill or
yoga or
inner dimensions of your life if you
have prepared yourself on any of these
things that is the time when it can
Propel or that is the time when it can
start crashing
you know in the western societies they
talk about mid-life crisis
it usually starts around 33 34 years of
age
suddenly people don't know what to do
with themselves
life getting meaningless or those who
are successful they find
traction and suddenly they explode into
different levels of success or
well-being
all this can happen
because
within the system it has completed a
certain cycle either it can take off or
it can crash you don't have to eliminate
the waste waste is very valuable if you
know right now in this Garden they buy
wasted a very and you know a very
exorbitant price because their waste
goes into the public system they have to
buy waste from somewhere they have to
buy a filth to fertilize yes yeah so
whether you turn your filth into a
fertilizer or you smear it on your face
and walk around that's your choice this
is why Karma
so what kind of karma happened in my
life till this moment is not always my
choice so many things have happened
but what kind of karma I perform right
now in this moment is 100 my choice will
I use this filth as manuals and Blossom
into your wonderful fragrance or will I
smear it around me and walk around with
filth this is the choice everybody has
when unpleasant things happen to us
which happens to everybody in some way
if you're living in the world I'm saying
unless you drop from somewhere else
right if you're living in this world so
many unpleasant things happen
now with these unpleasant things do you
become wise or do you become wounded
this is a choice to exercise this Choice
there must be a little space when I say
a little space where is your memory
stored
people think here your brain has very
little memory okay
every cell in the body carries a
trillion times more memory than your
entire brain
because if I take one cell from you we
can you know create you completely in a
lab that means what well your parents
your father and mother gave you only one
sell each they were not very generous
only one cell each see a whole man came
out of it yeah
so in that one cell all this memory head
to toe everything was there isn't it
yeah no mistake texture of the hair
texture of the skin the nails the works
every detail to the minutest detail was
it packed in that one cell or no yeah
yes so every cell in your body carries a
trillion times more memory than your
entire brain carries wow so if you do
not use that if you just use one part of
your body
then everything seems to be stressful
everything seems to be a struggle today
everybody complaining about everything
everything is stressful you are a
toddler you have stress of diapers you
are a teenager you have hormonal stress
your middle age you have a crisis your
old age geriatric stress right all right
which is not stressful entire life is
stress tell them okay you die oh that is
enormous stress so this is not because
there is something wrong with anybody's
life it's simply because it's like you
have a car it's supposed to go on four
wheels try to drive one one okay one may
look like too much try to drive one two
well within 10 miles your tires will
burst
because too much stress on one point
other things are not being used this all
that's happening to human beings pain is
not a concept if you don't know that
it's not a concept I can cause some pain
to you you will know it's not a concept
it's a living reality when you get it
hello
can pain be controlled by the mind
see pain is of the body
see suppose
this water is hardly nine inches deep
all right nine ten inches deep
but you want to dive from the top of the
tree
if there was no pain you would have done
it
[Applause]
yes
if it breaks your head and still there
is no pain a whole lot of people would
have done it
right now the only thing which is making
you behave sensibly at least in terms of
your survival is pain
without pain most people would not know
how to survive either
so pain is a very good thing it manages
you even emotional pain
that you cause
because you want to be a tragic hero
[Laughter]
see there is only physical pain as
existentially true
pain that you have in your mind and in
your emotion is caused by you
you like to poke yourself
why
because you're away in life
you have not found any other way to feel
profound
pain makes you feel profound
[Applause]
you're from Mumbai cinema world I'm
saying without pain no profoundness
isn't it no Artistry people think
they're profound because they're in pain
no your misunderstanding pain for
profoundness it's a serious mistake
if it comes in loads then you will know
what it is all right
it'll destroy you
it'll mutilate life pain yes or no
human beings have been destroyed not
necessarily by a sword or a gun they
just break themselves down into pieces
because of their own emotions and
thoughts
more people are mutilating themselves by
themselves using the sharpness of their
own mind rather than by somebody's sword
or gone isn't it so
why is this so
because you have misunderstood a few
fundamental things
you do not know what is real and what is
not what is existentially true what is
physiologically true what is
psychologically true do you have lost
you know the boundaries of this once you
lose this whatever you do it'll hurt you
just tell me one thing people are not
suffering
tell me one thing
well if they are poor they suffer their
poverty you make them Rich they suffer
the taxes
yes
if they are not educated they suffer
that put them to school they suffer that
uh they're not married they suffer that
get them married oh
[Music]
don't tell me no children they suffer
that give them children daily suffering
yes
so it looks like you're suffering every
aspect of life
so we'll offer you depth Oh They'll
suffer that
so suffering is not because of life
situations
suffering is because you do not know how
to manage yourself
you do not know how to manage your own
mind your emotion your energy your
your very life you do not know how to
manage then everything becomes suffering
physical pain is a different thing
physical pain is caused by some contact
or disease or injury or something
that of course we must see how we keep
it at the minimum in our life mosquito
bites you all right
but you don't have to be bitten by a
bear
you need to avoid that
Joy or misery Agony or ecstasy pleasure
of pain everything comes from within you
if you understand this much
if I understand
suppose right now I think I'm miserable
because of you
there's no solution for my life isn't it
because all you have to do is walk in
front of my home I will become miserable
so simple it is you don't have to kill
me you just have to walk around in front
of me I will die within myself every day
if I understand the source of my joy and
misery are within me
then you know what's the obvious choice
Joy the obvious choice isn't it
so this one fundamental thing has to get
across to all the human beings on this
planet
your experience is entirely determined
by you
this is what the word Karma means
unfortunately it's become something else
here
Karma means action that means when we
say your life is your karma we are
saying your life is entirely your making
100 percent
what happens in the world there are many
many forces involved what happens within
me it's one hundred percent me
100 percent isn't it yeah
if you don't take charge of this
then you're an accidental life when
you're an accidental life anxiety is
very natural
incentive um suppose you're driving
accidentally
that is you don't know what's happening
and you're simply somehow going anxiety
is natural or no yes
any accidental moment creates anxiety
so this is why Consciousness means this
that you have taken charge of the
instruments of life
which on most fundamental level is our
physiological and psychological space
you're taking charge of this
now your health your happiness your joy
your ecstasy your misery everything is
in your hands
you exercise them as you want
see there is uh scientific evidence to
show
at least 20 percent of your energy right
now as you sit here in a restful state
is being consumed by your brain
if you bring this down
that your brain is not unnecessarily
fluctuating and you know
hopping mad
all the time
if it learns to still be still and do
only what's needed
an enormous sense of personal power will
develop
you can't do this with your mind right
now if you try to stop it it will hop
even more crazy
at least do it with your body
your words and your physical moments
reduce it by 50 percent
if you want to look at this look at this
you want to look at that look at that
don't do this this
with your body and your
utterances if you do this slowly it will
also start manifesting in your mind it
will not do unnecessary things
when you don't know unnecessary things
the energy that you have slowly
transforms itself into potential power
life is an openness death is closing
isn't it
death is a closure life is a possibility
if you're just alive everything is open
tell me can you be alive suppose you
don't like me
so you don't want to inhale what I
exhale
stop breathing and exist for some time
let me see possible yes without
breathing
for a little while
how is little how much is little for you
to hold my breath yeah
I don't know 30 seconds 10 seconds 10
minutes definitely not 10 minutes
so I'm saying if you don't like me your
dislike will not go away in 30 seconds
isn't it yeah for sure suppose I hate
you I don't want to be inhale what you
exhale
I will die Within Myself isn't it yes
yes this all people are doing to
themselves I like this guy I don't like
that guy this is uh somebody I love that
somebody I hate this is belongs to me
this doesn't belong to me they're just
killing themselves step by step
they are planning to die in installments
if you want to live here you are you
must make up your mind whether you want
to live or you want to die you want to
know the certainty of death in life
this is called belief this is called
belonging this is called identification
because you are trying to find the
certainty of death in the seamless
process of life
it's very interesting this happened that
the Cincinnati airport in Ohio United
States
people had lined up to check in at the
airline ticket booth
one man just skipped the line and came
straight in the front and thrust his
ticket
the lady at the counter she said sir
there is a line
he said no no I'm in a hurry
she said everybody's in a hurry you're
on the same plane
please stand in the line
then he said do you know who I am
she looked at him promptly picked up the
microphone and said there is a man here
who does not know who he is can somebody
help him
so
who am I
is not a question that you ask somebody
it's a question that you ask yourself
make it more and more profound
something will get you money something
will get you comfort that's not the
point what you choose to do will it give
you a life
when I say give it give you a life are
you just trying to make a living or are
you trying to make a life out of this
it's important
making a living is not an issue a worm a
insect a bird an animal all of them are
making their life making a living isn't
it so
that even making a life out of it but
definitely they're making a living
so making a living with such a big brain
is not an issue
earning your food is not an issue making
a living is not an issue only problem is
you want to live like somebody else
that's an endless problem
I want to live is not a problem I want
to live like you this is a problem
so it is important if you consider your
life as a precious life you must make
sure you make a wonderful life out of
this
don't pursue enlightenment
you cannot pursue enlightenment
how can you pursue something that you do
not know
if you pursue something you will pursue
only what you know
what is the point pursuing something
that you already know
what is the point in running after
something that you already know
so if you have to step into something
that you do not know
the only thing is just to keep walking
keep a steady Direction and keep working
maybe it's the wrong direction it
doesn't matter just keep working after
all planet is round
inevitably
if you keep walking and keep straight
walking not round and round
if you just keep straight walking
you will inevitably get somewhere
nobody can take it away from you
you know
if you have a dog at home you would know
this if you just tickle him in the tail
he will go shh
chasing his own tail
okay A lot of people are doing that
they don't tell they're chasing
even Enlightenment is their own Tale
nobody told you there is such a thing
but
definitely you can see
from one person to another person
one person seems to be little better off
simply the way they are not because of
their money not because of their wealth
not because of their qualifications
simply the way they sit and stand
somebody seems to be better off than
somebody else
yes or no
so there is room and scope for
improvement
relentlessly improve let's see where it
gets you
but if you have fancy ideas of what is
enlightenment
then you will chase that silly idea
and that idea is never enlightenment
because it's your idea in your book you
talk about something I thought was so
interesting to set the faucet to a
certain drip rate and do nothing but
focus on the dripping of the fossa for
like seven minutes or something the idea
is to pay attention to something which
has no relevance to you
say people are have divided the universe
this is important this is not important
this person is important for me this
person is not important this is
important for me that's not important
for me you divided the universe you will
never know anything this way
indiscriminate Focus indiscriminate
attention I am not attending to you
because you are somebody with a cobra in
your heart all right
it doesn't matter who I speak to who I
am with I'm the same way
indiscriminate
only when your attention and involvement
is indiscriminate thus the universe open
up to you
you have discriminated naturally you
close you know people come to me and say
Sad Guru I want to walk the spiritual
path
I say okay
be here for three days let's see what we
can do day after tomorrow my uncle's
daughter's birthday I have to go
oh you want to get enlightened and Day
After Tomorrow uncle's daughter's
birthday also all right
we got one and a half days
you do one thing you do this this and
this this is but I don't like this
all right I'll give them a small piece
of paper
and say okay write down things that you
like we'll do only do that
you won't believe it in this entire
universe most people like only three or
four things
when you are so constipated in your head
that you lack only three or four people
or three or four things in your life how
do you want to open up to the existence
because life is happening because of its
openness
this is a fundamental difference between
death and life is people are thinking
it's just breath all right on one level
that is also openness whether you allow
this to happen or you don't allow it to
happen
whether you did it consciously or
unconsciously but it's happening isn't
it openness is on every subatomic
particle is in communication with
everything that's why this is going on
breath is happening so much is happening
in connection with everything it is only
in openness you're alive
as you close doors you are dying in
installments
dying in installments is torture
see
life is fantastic if you're alive and
fully alive
if you're dead it's good at least the
neighbors may think so
this may sound very not so compassionate
but I'm saying everybody dies you and me
will die all right
if you're dead it's the game is over
but if you're half dead oh
this is endless torture to yourself when
you are being tortured of course you
will share it with everybody else
you must decide
what is the highest value in your life
freedom
or bondage
please I would like to hear that word
but
if you are free
you feel lost
if some if you go into the mountains
and you're totally free that is nobody
around nothing around you just in the
empty space of the mountains
you don't feel free you think you're
lost
so to handle Freedom it needs a certain
Clarity and strength
most people cannot handle freedom
they are always trying to bind my bind
themselves but only talking mouthing
Freedom all the time if you really set
them free they will suffer immensely
so this is uh
evolutionary issue
in the sense
human beings are right now like this a
caged bird if you keep a bird cage for a
long period of time and then one day you
took off the door of the cage
still the bird won't fly
from inside it will protest that it's
not free but it will not fly
Human Condition is just that
for all other creatures nature is drawn
Two Lines within which they have to live
and die and that's what they do
but only for human beings
there's only bottom line there's no Top
Line
and that's what they're suffering
if their life was also fixed like every
other creature's life they wouldn't be
stressed they would be anxious they
wouldn't be struggling how to handle
their own intelligence
and that is what you're seeking
unknowingly
you may have seek it in the form of
relationships you may seek it in the
form of profession you may seek it in
the form of form of nationality
ethnicity community
God Heaven hell all you are trying to do
is draw an artificial line which does
not exist
because Freedom needs courage
Freedom needs I said in Madness
if you're very sane you cannot be free
because you will go between the two
lines of logic
to be free it takes a lot of strength
that if you first of all what needs to
happen if you want to be free is
do you understand that all Human
Experience
has a chemical basis to it
hello
what you call is joy is one kind of
chemistry misery is another kind of
chemistry stress is one kind of
chemistry
anxiety another kind of chemistry Agony
one kind of chemistry ecstasy another
kind of chemistry at least ecstasy you
know it's another kind of chemistry
I hear
so your experience of life has a
chemical basis to it there's a more
superficial way of looking at it there
are other dimensions to it but for your
understanding
or in other words what you call as
myself right now you're a chemical soup
the question is only are you a great
soup or a lousy soup
yes or no
right now if you have a chemistry of
blissfulness
if you close your eyes it's fantastic if
you open your eyes it's fantastic if
somebody is here it's fantastic nobody
is here it's very fantastic yes or no
but you have a lousy chemistry
if you look at them if they smile at you
it's nice not fantastic if they look at
you like this suddenly it's a problem
if these people are happening just the
way you want your chemistry is
reasonably balanced
if they do something that you don't like
boom it goes somewhere else
so essentially
you have not looked at this mechanism
what is the basis of this how it
functions how I can make it function at
its highest level
right now let's say you really blissed
out like me
do you care who is around who is not
around
if they're around it's fantastic
they go on fantastic
because your experience of life is no
more determined by what you have and
what you don't have whether it's people
or things or food or this or that it is
not determined by that
once your way of being is not determined
by anything outside of you
then there is no such thing as
loneliness
but you will enjoy your aloneness
because whether you like it or you don't
like it at this young age it's a little
uh difficult to understand this whether
you like it or you don't like it within
this body you're always alone isn't it
whether you do interaction or
intercourse or whatever whatever
still you're alone in this body yes or
no
hello
[Applause]
if you don't learn how to handle this
aloneness you have not learned anything
about life
this is the most beautiful thing
the most beautiful thing about life is
nobody can get here it's just my space
yes or no
isn't this the most beautiful thing
nobody can invade me they can capture me
they can torture me they can do so many
things but they cannot invade me because
I have a space which is just my own
isn't this the most wonderful aspect of
your life
don't suffer that that is the most
beautiful thing
we are thinking of Happiness like it's
some kind of a commodity
or some kind of an attainment
no when your life comes to ease when you
come to ease
happiness is a natural consequence
coming to ease what does that mean there
are many ways to look at this
well
because I should not say look inward
you already put a condition on me
so is it true that today even medically
we know
every human experience has a chemical
basis to it
so what you call as peace is one kind of
chemistry happiness is another kind of
chemistry Joy is another kind of
chemistry misery is another kind of
chemistry Agony is one kind of chemistry
ecstasy is another kind of chemistry
every human experience has a chemical
basis to it
or in other words
you are a very complex chemical soup
the question is only are you a great
soup or a lousy soup
if you're a great soup you taste good
not for somebody for yourself when you
taste very good for yourself if you sit
here if you feel extremely Pleasant
within yourself because the soup is
great
then people say you are happy
if you become very very pleasant people
say you're joyful if you become super
Pleasant people will say you're ecstatic
so to make it very simple and
understandable for most people
your Chemistry needs to be altered
there's a whole technology with which we
can create the kind of chemistry that
you want if I teach you how to create a
blissful chemistry within yourself your
very chemistry is blissful and you will
be Blissful when you're Blissful you
will no more be in Pursuit of Happiness
that is the biggest mistake that we are
in pursuit of happiness
your life has to become an expression of
joy
when your life is an expression of your
experience
then
what you do what you do not do will not
determine the quality of your life how
you are within yourself will determine
the quality of your life I am sorry once
again I use the word within but
chemistry is not within it is still
outside of you
but
if you know how to make the right soup
then being joyful is not an issue it's a
natural consequence of that
so we can teach you a technology we can
teach you a methodology with which
you will know how to stir the right kind
of soup within you
this is what I am calling as in
engineering that you engineer your
Chemistry in such a way that it's
Blissful by its own nature not because
of something
if you think you're going to squeeze
happiness out of something or somebody
you will be disappointed because nothing
will yield anything
unless you have a chemistry of
blissfulness within you so let us not
think anger happens to us resentment
happens to us no these things we are
creating
we have the power to emote we can make
it love we can make it joy we can make
it Ecstasy but people have chosen to
make it tension anger resentment hatred
they have turned it that way now they
will claim this is because life has been
unfair to me life has not been fair to
anybody
especially not me
life is not fair to anybody life is
simply rolling it's for you to learn to
write it sometimes we're in
uncomfortable situations some sometimes
we're in comfortable situations
sometimes we are in situations where we
know exactly what to do and sometimes
we're in situations where we don't know
what to do sometimes somebody else is
controlling the situation sometimes
you're controlling the situation this is
how life is if you are constantly
stepping into unfamiliar situations in
your life that means you are growing at
a rapid Pace if you are in constantly in
comfortable situations that means you
are a stagnant life
um
so if you if you look for Comfort if you
look for a comfort zone because the
moment your thoughts and emotions are
going to torment you with external
stimulant external stimulation that
happens what will you Choose You will
choose a comfort zone this means you
will limit your life so the moment
somebody can cause you pain or suffering
this means unknowingly you will make the
very scope of your life very limited
only when a person loses this fear of
suffering that no matter what happens
this is how I will be if this assurance
comes to you then you walk full stride
because
whatever happens in the life around you
it will not really make you suffer once
you are free from suffering only when
you're free from suffering when you're
free from the fear of suffering that is
when you will explore your life in full
depth and dimension if you do bad things
bad things will come for you
this has been the way of the world you
don't need the word karma for that
because people have been trying to
control people either with fear or guilt
this has been the basis of a whole lot
of things happening in the world if you
do this you will go to hell if you do
that you will go to heaven otherwise
here itself it will happen to you
whatever
or there is somebody up there with a
stick waiting and they will vacuum
all these kind of things essentially
you're trying to manage Humanity
control Humanity
with uh
fear or guilt yeah
fear and guilt I see particularly in the
western world is like enormous it is in
the psyche of people in such a big way
[Music]
well karma is not about fear karma is
not about guilt karma is about
liberation
it is about freedom
because you are a composite as you sit
here your composite of various memories
within you yes
it goes back
it goes way back but let's start with
amoeba in recent times
okay so mommy go to now the whole
evolutionary process in some ways
recorded in this body
otherwise this body would be confused
every other day whether this is human or
not
this is 100 clear that this is human
this is evolutionary memory always there
there is genetic memory there is karmic
memory there is articulate in articulate
you know unconscious subconscious and
conscious memories right now when we say
memory people think only of their
conscious memory which is less than one
percent of their actual memory so the
things they actually remember in their
mind the conscious memory that is less
than one percent of the actual memory
so for example I can give you a thousand
examples like this which are manifesting
in everybody's life the simple thing is
this uh let's say 500 years ago how your
great great grandfather was you don't
remember for sure no but his nose is
sitting on your face probably right my
ears are his ears yeah yep many things
yeah even the color of the skin and the
texture of the skin everything
so the minute is details of what
happened to your forefathers a million
years ago still living with you right
now wow it is living with you right now
all these memories a composite or an
amalgamation of all these complex
memories is what you call as myself
what you call is myself consciously
maybe just a small part of that but that
small part is happening because of this
massive memory that is there if they're
only looking at the phone screen or the
computer screen they're heading into
your wall
you need to look up and see where is
life going around you it's very
important your misunderstanding
technology and uh you know the screen
space as a reality no it's a technology
is a wonderful tool only if you use it
consciously
if you become unconscious and compulsive
about it today in United States they've
set up a technology de addiction centers
okay just like drug de addiction
technology addiction they're going crazy
with technology
technology has done wonders to me
we are doing 100 times the work that we
were doing uh maybe 15 20 years ago
simply because of technology I think
it's a great thing but somebody else is
suffering that human beings are even
suffering their own brains isn't it
if they didn't have a brain they would
be peaceful
because they have a brain they think
stress stress stress because you don't
know how to handle the highest
technology which is here
on this planet the greatest technology
in the planet is the human mechanism
people who don't know how to handle it
people who never read the user's manual
they are suffering their body and their
mind
you own something not because it's
useful to you if it's useful to you you
enjoy using it please have it Whatever
It Is
but you are having it only because
others don't have it
this is a sickness
this will naturally happen to you if you
enhance your intellect
without enhancing other aspects of your
intelligence
because the nature of the intellect is
to accumulate
today you call it as information you
call it as data essentially it is
accumulation
and because of this information
we have given up on human attention
it is only with human attention you can
open any door in the universe
keenness of your attention will do that
but today
right now I've looked up a Wikipedia of
all of you guys I know everything about
you I don't have to look at you
this is how we have become hello
because I have information in my head I
don't have to pay attention
see whatever information let's say if I
take one of you as an example if I have
all the information about you about your
life
still it could be wrong this moment
because a human being is a possibility
this moment you may be something other
than what information I have isn't it so
if I am not open to that possibility I
am missing the whole human being
because a data doesn't make life
data is the footprint of life not life
if you see my footprint
that's not me isn't it
and the whole once you are thinking
about accumulations the next thing is
you want to leave a footprint
those who want to leave a footprint in
this world they shall never fly
people think I have knowledge no my head
is empty that's why to make it little
look look little substantial I have a
turbine
it's totally empty always
but I have Clarity Clarity means what
you see things the way they are
knowledge means what
you have fixed information about
everything if things have changed you
will not see it the way it is
that's as good as being blank
say people think owls are blind
it's not true their vision is far more
sensitive than yours
but because of sunlight they're blinded
because it's too much
when light goes down he sees very
clearly not because he's blind because
his eyes are super sensitive
so it's important that you bring Clarity
to your life not knowledge because
knowledge is conclusions that you gather
knowledge is okay when you're trying to
do something physical material in the
world but not with life
is it true
what you thought was absolute at the age
of 12 today is not true
yes or no
are you sure that whatever you think is
this is it right now will be this is it
in another three years time of course
not
you know that so you know you're wrong
yes sir no yes so you know anyway you're
wrong so why assert the wrong things
well right now we are wrong at least
let's manage with little
little more conscious if you know you're
wrong you will walk carefully isn't it
hello
but you you think you're absolutely
correct then you will do stupid things
and you blunder around the world
if you know you're not seeing properly
will you walk carefully or not
if I asked you to walk through a dark
room suppose we turn off all the lights
and close it down everything pitch dark
if I ask you to walk suddenly will you
become super alert and conscious as to
how you walk
but when the lights are on
you just going unconsciously bumping
into everybody
so if you learn to walk every moment
like there are no lights and you're
looking at everything absolutely
carefully
then what you see clearly you go through
it what you don't see see clearly you
hesitate some places you take a little
bit of chance
but if you are just confident
you will blunder through life we don't
know where you will get in
and what you will get trapped into
most people are trapped into their
professions their family situations
their social situations in such a way
they all became like
yes already I am saying
not just older people youth have become
like this
what will happen to me at the end of my
life what will happen to me at the end
of my life I'm already revealed the
secret you will die
but sadhguru if this happens what to do
if that happens what to do all those
things will happen
it's not that everything will happen in
your life the way you like it things
will happen in the way you don't like it
it once happened Shankar and pillai got
fired from his job
simply because he asked a question
smoking or not smoke non-smoking
how can you get fired for asking such a
simple question
smoking or non-smoking he asked and he
got fired
because what he was supposed to ask was
cremation or burial
so many times what you do thinking I am
right may be irrelevant to the situation
in which you exist
so the most important aspect of your
life is your relevant
not right
you're just relevant to the existing
situation you're relevant I am right I
am right I am right
this is confidence you being right
nobody cares all the idiots who think
they are right nobody wants to listen to
them nobody wants to be around them
isn't it
people who always think I am right I am
right you want to be around them
now the important thing is you're
relevant to the situation in which you
exist if you have to bring relevance
into your life you must extinguish your
confidence and bring Clarity you should
not be a motivated person generally
[Music]
somebody when we say somebody is
motivated
it means they have an agenda of Their
Own
Life Has No Agenda it's for you to be a
full-fledged life a grasshopper is
trying to be a full-fledged grasshopper
earthworm is trying to be a full-fledged
earthworm a bird is trying to be a
full-fledged bird a tree is trying to be
a full-fledged tree a human being should
strive to become a full-fledged human
being
this is all our businesses
but each one of us start creating our
own agendas
and doing all kinds of things no no
you're just a piece of life don't take
yourself too seriously
because before you and me countless
number of people have come and gone
yes or no
where are they
all those people
you think they were all idiots
they were all idiots and they died is it
no they were also like you maybe they
were also officers maybe they were Kings
more than you all kinds of things
all topsoil now
this will also become top soil
just a little bit of time life is a bit
of a sparkle
[Music]
how old is your sunshine
so 27 years ago where was he sir
so if somebody is not here we say
they're dead isn't it
27 years ago he was dead
we will give him 100 Years sir eight
years later
he will be again dead
he said no
so 27 years ago how long was the dead
Fair
huh
long time
so 85 years later or 80 years later how
long will he be dead sir
very long time
so all of us will be dead for a very
long time
they're alive just for a brief amount of
time
yes very brief amount of time
we will be dead for a very long time I
want you to look at it in this
perspective how long will you be dead
you can't imagine so let us say
10 000 years we are dead or hundred
thousand years they are dead or a
million years we are dead all right
how long are you alive compared to that
very very brief what you call is life is
a brief Sparkle the only thing that you
have to do is rise and Sparkle as a
full-fledged life
when something is needed around us we
will do that naturally because when
you're doing wonderfully well you will
do what is needed isn't it
when you are miserable you will be
motivated
yes
tell me when you're very happy have you
looked at yourself how nice and
wonderful you are you're willing to do
anything for anybody you bend backwards
if necessary yes or no
when you're little frustrated
whoa
how difficult it is so don't teach your
children to become motivated about
something these are all nonsense that's
coming from the West all those trashy
self-help books motivate yourself build
confidence believe in yourself you
believed in God and destroyed so much of
this world now you believe in yourself
what will you do
when Gautama
the Buddha was asked
is it better to walk alone
or in company
he said
it's better to walk alone than to walk
with a fool
well
that's him not me
he was quite sure that only a fool will
walk with you
so he said it's better to walk alone
than to walk with the fool
certain lore in this country
says
when you want to do a short and quick
Journey Walk Alone
when you want to do a long journey walk
in company
but the important thing is who is
walking with you
not always being together is a good
thing
many times
being together can be a new sense
so
first and foremost
unless you are a twin
even then
we come along and we go along
if one does not know
how to be by himself
or herself
then being together can be a lot of
nuisance
we are referred to as human beings
human beings means
every other creature
is what it is simply because of what he
does
but a human being can simply be
which is a unique quality of the human
being
that we can simply be that we are not
compulsive action that's what it means
our action is conscious and judicious
but generally when people get together
generally
people are in compulsive action
it can be an association where there
could be a purposeful action
or it can be a gang where there can be
more purposeful action
or it can be a crowd which can be a
compulsive action
so essentially to be human means
we have reached that point of evolution
within ourselves
that if we wish we can simply sit here
just be
we can consider
as to what action to take and what not
to take
this is definitely individual
when individuals come together
we say
it's we in
in plural
but still it is individuals who have to
come together
to be an individual means
you are not further divisible
that means you just want
people find different ways to divide
themselves within themselves
in India with eight and thousand years
of cultural history
we have invented various words to divide
ourselves
it's very common for people to talk in
terms of Atma paramatma Ankara this one
and that one
but every every culture has this in
their own way
when things are going right
when good things are being done if you
ask people they say yes I did it
when things don't go right when things
go wrong
then they will try to find somebody if
they don't find anybody
he is always there
when they are very wonderful
of course they take pride in being how
wonderful they are
when they turn nasty they say it was my
ego
Mr ego is always a Fall Guy
so individual means
but if I'm wonderful it's me if I'm
nasty it's me all of you
are you 24 hours wonderful
hello
no no sometimes wonderful sometimes
nasty sometimes beautiful sometimes ugly
it's okay
if we understand it is me who is capable
of being absolutely wonderful and it is
me who is capable of being absolutely
nasty another moment
then gradually the number of moments of
nastiness will keep on receding
if I see
what is wonderful is me what is nastiest
in India we have many words it's my
karma what can I do
now you must fix this
being an individual is very important
that means you're not further divisible
if I am wonderful it's me if I'm nasty
it's me
if I succeed it's me if I fail it's me
you have to fix this
let one human being honestly say
when you are with your most loving
parents however doting and wonderful
they were to you
that you never felt this is not where
you want to be
that is a dishonest human being
because
love gets tedious
somebody's fondness gets very tedious
Comfort gets tedious
because the nature of life is it wants
to constantly expand
if there is no room for expansion it
doesn't matter you are kept in a uh
whatever I won't use because everybody
uses the word Golden Palace I think
Golden Palace is totally anesthetic in
my uh
my visual perception I hate Golden
Palace but whatever is the most
wonderful Palace
or as you say Shangri-La or whatever
you will it will get tedious
all the heaven-bound people
they don't know how bored they will be
within three days in that place of
goodness
so I am saying it doesn't matter it's
not because there's something wrong with
your parents
they may be most wonderful people
but
the very nature of a human being is such
only if you are a pet animal
if you have reduced yourself to that
you're just happy
with the means that you're getting and
somebody is fondling you once in a way
and you're happy with that
for that you must be a pet animal you
should not be born as a human being once
you're born as a human being it is
natural wanting to break
barriers so when you're young as a child
or a teenager you think barriers means
they're all physical before you
understand the barriers are not really
physical whether you build your own
house or you live in your parents house
or you live in a slave master's house
the house and walls are not the barrier
it is all within us before you realize
that or how soon you realize that will
lead to either transformation or
frustration
you can simply sit
if you learn to Simply sit
you will become tremendously intense
right now your energy is simply expanded
by doing unnecessary
endless activity
when you have so much
mental diarrhea how can you have energy
suppose you have diarrhea do you see how
weak you feel
so no
right now this mental diarrhea that's
why people have no energy
they want to just eat and sleep all the
time because mental diarrhea is very
exhausting
if you have physical diarrhea you know
how exhausting it is
yes
this is also equally exhausting
people are sleeping eight hours ten
hours a day
not because they are working so much or
their body is in such a bad state
just mental diarrhea
if you stop the mental diarrhea there's
enough energy to make this very very
intense
now how do I stop mental area
if you have diarrhea physical diarrhea
what is the first thing to do
huh
what
yes run to the toilet I know that
I'm saying yeah as a as a corrective
measure what is the first thing you do
[Music]
no as a corrective measure what is the
first thing you do
first thing is stop eating right
I should know
but diarrhea means in some way we've
eaten something
that the body doesn't want
it's trying to throw it out
yes
you've taken something inside which the
body doesn't like it wants to throw it
out
first thing is
stay away from food for some time
you eat bad food and then try to stop
diarrhea it's not going to work
so similarly bad food for the mind is
just this
you have gotten identified with things
that you are not
the moment you get identified with
things that you are not
mental diarrhea is inevitable
it's bad food for the mind now it will
run endlessly do what you want you do
any damn meditation you say Shiva Rama
it's not going to stop
it's not stopped isn't it
because bad food is being eaten every
day you're getting identified with more
and more things and you want to stop
your mind
you do whatever kind of circus
it is not going to stop
if you disidentify with everything
if you understand what is you and what
is not you
if you keep a little distance from that
mind will become still
if you want you can use it otherwise you
can keep it
now my hand is there if I want I can
move it otherwise I can keep it this is
a useful hand suppose it starts jumping
like this
[Music]
you clearly know
there is some kind of an ailment isn't
it
yes or no
so if hand is jumping you know it's an
ailment if mind is jumping is it an
ailment or no
the element has come because continuous
wrong diet
you tell your mind
that I am this I am this I am that I am
that
it's having diarrhea
you stop giving it wrong food
if you clearly see what even if you do
not know what is me at least you know
what is not me isn't it
this much you do
tonight before you go to bed
sit on your bed
and sit down
and discount everything that is not you
this house in Europe in which you are
living is this me
no
this loving parent or mother father wife
or husband or child
they're wonderful but is this me
no
no it is nice clothes I am wearing is
this me no
now my body I like it but is this me no
now I am having so many thoughts is this
me no
now I'm having wonderful emotions is
this me no
like this everything that's not you
before you sleep keep it down and go to
bed
tomorrow morning you will wake up
considerably more intense than today
this happened in your school maybe later
in your University later in your work
it's happening to people maybe not
everyone but a whole lot of people
their commitment to success is weak
they want to succeed they will take
three steps then something little
interesting happens here they will go
away here they will go over there
they'll go over there hey I want to live
their commitment to success is weak
uh either situations around them in some
way you know situations can impede you
from doing what you're doing very easily
many times it happens to everyone
but when this happens people weaken
their commitment for their success
maybe physically they'll feel a little
weak
they will weaken their commitment to
success maybe their emotions loss around
a little bit
they will weaken their commitment to
success
this is very important right now
however long it takes this virus
you must come out of this successfully
that means you will stay alive that's an
important part
and
commitment to staying alive
should not be slackened no matter what
happened somebody very dear to us passed
away all the more important we must live
[Music]
people around us are all sick all the
more important we are healthy
to take care of the people around us
so our commitment to success should not
weaken because there is social drama
going on or physiological drama or
psychological drama whatever happens
your commitment to success should not
weaken that is what get you across so
many lines in our life so many barriers
in our life
so uh what does success look like
what does it take
just understand
those who made any significant
achievements in their life
uh they did not
you know
I don't want to take any personal
examples of anybody I'm trying to avoid
obvious things that are coming to my
mind
yeah
well
[Music]
you know I know
family and friends
who always have their breakfast on time
and after breakfast of course they must
have coffee
after coffee of course they must light
up a cigarette and sit there nicely
because they're trying to
become peaceful
foreign and then they will go to work
come back home exactly on time for lunch
eat lunch
rest for one or two hours sleep
then evening have one tea and then smoke
and then again go to work
and ate eight eight o'clock 8 30 they're
back home for dinner and then maybe
other things drink and this and that and
whatever
well that's their priority
it's fine I'm not complaining it should
not be that way
but those who have been very successful
either in music sport art business
spiritual process doesn't matter what
those people
never know when they ate when they slept
when they got afternoon rest I have not
seen such a thing in my life
so uh
those who are committed to being
successful with whatever they are doing
one important aspect of their life is
they're not settling down wherever it's
a bit comfortable
because Comfort will happen when they
lower you to in the grave very
comfortable you are you know
see every creature
from a warm insect bird plant tree
everybody
all of them are trying to be
full-fledged lives
if one sees
what's happening beneath the Earth in
terms of the root systems
it is an enormous effort
for a plant or a tree to become a a
full-fledged tree
well an apple tree is not trying to be
an oak tree
but an apple tree wants to be a
full-fledged apple tree
that effort is on in every life
so is it in human beings
but the problem with humanity is just
this
that for every other creature nature is
drawn two lines
Within These two lines they live and die
so their idea of full-fledged is hitting
the ceiling of their life
but if a human being hits a ceiling he
gets frustrated and miserable
because
nature this process of evolution has
delivered to us to a place where there
is only the bottom line there is no Top
Line though some human beings are trying
to breach the bottom line and go below
that effort also is going on
so essentially what human life is is
when life was in the other forms of life
that you see on the planet
nature determined a certain compulsive
instinctive ways of functioning
once you become human these lines have
been removed
you can act consciously that means what
you call as human potential is not of
any kind of measurable limit it can go
as far
as you desire or us as far as you have
the courage to walk
so when we say human potential
unleashing human potential
it is not about reaching the peak
it is a trajectory
because what our life is
is a combination of a certain amount of
time and energy
time is rolling away for all of us at
the same pace
if you sit it rolls away if you sleep it
rolls away if you do something it goes
away if you don't do anything it goes
away you're happy or miserable it goes
away
time is running out for all of us
so it's only the energy that you can
do different things with if you bring
your energies to a certain level of
intensity and possibility
what somebody does in 10 years you may
do it in one year this means if you live
here for 100 years it feels like in
people's impact that you have created it
feels like you lived here for a thousand
years simply because you have managed
your life energies in a certain way
so for me a human being being impactful
means how conscious have you become this
is very important because if you're in
compulsive Cycles then your energy gets
wasted in so many things if you absorb
people
in a day let's say let's take 24 hours
in that anyway most people by
prescription in America they sleep for
eight hours
so eight hours means one third of life
is gone
in the remaining two-thirds they have to
eat they have to you know shower
bathroom this that all this another two
three hours gone
so literally 50 percent of life is gone
daily basis just for basic maintenance
of this life
fifty percent of the time is gone in
maintenance remaining fifty percent what
they have if you look at every single
move that they may make with their body
their thought process their emotions you
will see a whole lot of it is happening
in compulsive Cycles
or in other words if you are little
sensitive to life you will realize you
are the biggest issue in your life
so this is one thing that I'm trying to
do with people that you are never the
issue in your life
I am not the issue my thought my emotion
my body is never the issue
my thought my emotion my energy and my
body are my instruments a function they
are not impediments in my life but I
would say for 90 of the human beings
their own body then the compulsions of
the body the compulsions of their
thought the compulsions of their
emotions
or ruling them most of the time
so when you yourself are a problem
well your own self-help I don't know I
never looked at Life as a series of
mistakes learning from that I don't look
at life like that
well
have you done made some dumb decisions
here and there of course
uh
I wouldn't see them as mistakes I just
see them as part of growing up and
becoming more mature because
Enlightenment is one thing you see
things clearly but still operating in
the world you need wisdom wisdom you
have to earn it with experience there is
simply no other way for that today it
has become fashionable with all these
management gurus and all saying You must
learn from your mistakes you must learn
mistakes that means you must keep on
doing mistakes I don't believe that you
must learn from your mistakes I would
rather live a life where I don't do any
mistakes
because life is so brief you do a bunch
of mistakes and then you will learn and
where will you use it in the grave yes
of Being Human means that we can learn
from other people's experience from
history we can learn we don't have to do
all those things once again and
especially you are from the aviation
state if you are trying Aviation or if
you're trying skydiving or something if
you don't do things right the first time
well that will be the last time it's a
pain is physiological it's there it was
no pain most people would not even know
how to protect themselves
see just because there's no pain in the
sea what all you've done to it
isn't it see there's no pain in this so
that's why you
took it off if there's no pain in your
nose
maybe you would have taken it off right
because there are many advantages you
will take in about 22 extra oxygen if
you just remove this one thing
contraption
[Laughter]
wherever there is no pain people are
messing with it like crazy isn't it they
call this hairstyle they call it so many
things yeah
Suppose there was no pain in the entire
body in Los Angeles people would pull
out their stomach bag and
you think they wouldn't do it no that's
probably what
only pain is helping them to preserve
themselves isn't it so pain is good
there's no physiological pain most
people would not know I hear in United
States there's one group they call
themselves something I forget that word
they're actually cutting their fingers
off their hands off on the video
wow they're posting it online
there's a group like that whoa can you
imagine this no in spite of so much pain
if there was no pain almost everybody
would have cut themselves off into in
the name of fashion they would have cut
themselves into ribbons wow
so pain is a good thing physically
because that is your
preservation self-preservation mechanism
but suffering is something that you do
in your mind
so pain that happens in your body you
take it in your mind and multiply it a
thousand times or a million times
depending on how capable you are or how
stupid you are and suffer it a million
times over
right now most human beings are like
this what happened 10 years ago they can
still suffer
what may happen day after tomorrow they
already suffer
they are not suffering life they think
they are suffering life they are not
suffering life they are suffering the
two most fantastic faculties that human
beings alone have a vivid sense of
memory and a fantastic sense of
imagination don't utter the word freedom
because freedom is a consequence it's
something that you have to earn it
doesn't come as a philosophy in 60s we
thought it's a philosophy
if you live responsibly you will see
Freedom will come when I say responsibly
not in the sense of civic responsibility
if you retain your ability to respond to
life
without any prejudice
without any restriction you will see you
will become free
your ability to respond if it is
unlimited it is freedom see first of all
people are assuming that anger is
happening to them or misery is happening
to them no this is exactly what I said
earlier maybe I didn't articulate it
fully no you are creating anger you are
creating misery you're creating Joy
you're creating whatever all this is
happening from within you but Human
Experience is happening from within us
isn't it right whether it's love or hate
or anger or misery or Joy or anything is
only happening from within us now simple
question I am asking is what happens
from within you should you have should
it happen your way or somebody else's
way
it should happen your way
of course because the world will never
happen your way hundred percent
because there are so many stakeholders
in the world little bit will happen my
way little bit your way that is fine but
what happens Within Me must happen my
way if what happens within me does not
happen my way this is the worst form of
slavery isn't it wow
somebody decides what happens within me
somebody decides where I should sit this
is slavery everybody understands this
now somebody decides whether I am
happier and happy isn't this the worst
form of slavery yeah
so this is The Liberation that Humanity
needs to work at this is what inner
engineering means inner engineering is
not some mechanical process because
engineering means this essentially you
will say something is well engineered
only if it works the way you want isn't
it
if this one doesn't work the way you
want what the hell are you expecting
other things to work the way you want
it's just an accident when you live
accidentally anxiety is normal
oh he or she is hot
now they say
you must see this one come here
come here come here
you must say houses laughing at every
joke
foreign
[Applause]
just do this one thing stop
discriminating what is important what is
not important
if you pay the same level of absolute
attention to every damn thing you will
see
that what is the right thing to do is a
very natural process
but you have already decided what is
important what is not important how will
you evolve what is the right thing to do
half the world has already been given up
because it's not important
you are paying attention only you even
look at somebody properly only if they
are of something to you
no I looked at everybody absolutely
every life every damn thing every Pebble
every moment that was happening in the
earth in the atmosphere everything not
as a study
simply because I had eyes
and I had an attention span I paid
attention to everything today they are
saying this is something phenomenal I
was just laughing and saying see I just
wandered aimlessly everybody thought I
am just a vagabond but now
this aimless wandering has is paying off
in a huge way
because it doesn't matter what the hell
you're doing small things are big things
if you are absolutely involved
absolutely
you will say you will know what's the
right thing to do
you trying to live here without
involvement this is why you have morals
you have ideals you have ideologies you
have values you have ethics you have
Commandments
because you are trying to live here
without involvement
you want ready-made formula what is the
right thing to do thou shall not thou
shall not thou shall not did the world
get fixed I'm asking
every goddamn school going children
knows what is the right thing to do has
it worked
it's not worked because you think there
is a substitute for involvement
there is no substitute for involvement
where there is no involvement there will
be no life
so don't try to make formulas
or ideals or ideologies out of life all
life takes is absolute involvement
unbridled involvement not distinguishing
who is who what is what just absolutely
involved with everything that you're in
touch with right now
if you do this one thing
well according to your level of
intelligence
and
you know nature also should heal
with all this you will know what is the
best thing to do given your perspective
of course
see right now if you bring a man of
certain capability
he may do something in a given situation
that's not the right thing to do for you
isn't it
you must know what is the right thing
for you to do in a given situation you
won't be able to do what he does
you must be able to do what you can do
to the best of your ability that is the
right thing to do in your life
you don't try to do like somebody else
so that will be the problem the moment
you decide what is the right thing to do
now
there is no ready-made solution
involvement
there is no substitute for involvement
where there is no involvement there is
no life Karma
probably
one of the most
misunderstood words
for sure it's become part of the English
lexicon today
but misunderstood
and misinterpreted in a million
different ways
a range of things
the very way
the nature of karma is just like that
its interpretations
the karmic structure is a very complex
mess
but
there is a
there are
very uh what to say very descriptive
stories
in the Indian culture about
the type of jewelry the courtesans used
to wear
that is very famous courtesans were
covered in gold and diamonds
no clothes only jewelry covered their
body
such complex jewelry
that
when
when a man who came to them
they had no clue how to take off this
jewelry because it was such a complex
web of chains
try as hard as they did but they cannot
get this Jewelry off
jewelry is beautiful
but
for a man who is
whose mind is running right with lust
this is a barrier
so usually uh
she encourages him to drink and drink
little more and little more
so that he sleeps
and gifts are more jewelry and goes home
but when she wants to take it off
there is just one pin normally located
at where our anahata is this one pin if
she proof pulls the entire jewelry falls
down in once
just like that it falls down
karma is like this it's a complex web of
chains
some of them of course decorated with
diamonds
some are ugly some are rusted chains but
chains and chains and chains but there
is just one single pin
only because
you are not able to consciously find the
PIN
the fundamental reason
let me tell you the fundamental reason
why there is a culture or there is a
tradition of
depending upon a guru
for one spiritual growth is just this
that you want him to
pull the plug when the time is right
because in this complex web of change
you don't know where the pin is
right now if you try to find it
you can go on a search Forever and not
find it and if you find it just in case
if you find it
you will dismantle it in such a way that
you will dismantle your very life
to dismantle it skillfully that just
what just the karmic aspect falls off
and you exist as a liberated being that
takes lots of skill it is for that skill
that you come to your Guru
it is your karma that you have to endure
me
if you had figured it out yourself you
didn't have to bother about me
so sadhguru when are you going to pull
my plug
that means it's not you're not ready yet
if you have if you are in a state where
you think your karma is a burden and you
must get rid of it you are not yet ready
for it
if you come to a state where
you have learned how to transform every
memory conscious and unconscious
Pleasant and unpleasant
beautiful and horrendous ones everything
into well-being
if you come to that state then it'll be
good for me to pull the pins
now if you feel the pain because
this is not Liberation this is an escape
there is difference between walking out
of this body
and committing suicide they're two
different things all together
committing suicide means you want to
escape a difficult situation
walking out of this means
your term is over your time is up so
they've released you
these are two different things
completely
if you escape from the prison you will
have to run for the rest of your life
but if you're freed from the prison
because your term is up then you're a
free man
that's a big difference
monotony is not life monotony is the
nature of the Mind
that is if you left your mind loose
without knowing how to employ it
so if you do not know how to use it mind
will use you in consume you
so the whole spiritual process is just
that
[Music]
every moment of your life if you just
look up
you're seeing a new piece of the sky
because the Earth is rotating
isn't it every moment if you look up
you are seeing a new piece of the sky
it's very exciting
[Music]
the Earth is spinning all the time
not one moment same old thing anyway
everything is changing
if you're alive to life you will never
know any monotone in your life
if you're not alive to life
but you just live in your mind then
everything will be monotonous because
mind is repetitive in nature
people who are just bored and rejected
and suffering the monotony of life
people come
to just a week-long or weekend program
and suddenly everything looks fresh for
them because
the Cataract on their eyes has been
cleared
so the cataracted mind has been cleared
and suddenly they find Everything Is
Beautiful for them all of a sudden
particularly people who go through the
BIOS banana for them they go out and
suddenly they're excited about
everything and the same old things
so the what is old essentially comes
because of your mind otherwise there's
nothing old in existence
modern science is proving to you beyond
any doubt
there is no such thing as old anywhere
everything is reverberating and creating
itself all the time
and a rock is pulsating with new life
every moment
but the world exists only in the mind
because mind functions out of past
memory
once your mind is repetitive you will
neither know peace
[Music]
nor Joy nor wisdom in your life
which time you meditate
and go beyond the step if it do this
um for everything there's a price that's
what you're saying
uh
you have to pay for everything
it's like this right now my left foot is
here my right foot is here if my right
foot wants to go here it has to equate
that space is a good song
no no I want to be here also but I want
to put my foot here is it possible
so now I can if I do it joyfully I don't
think this is a price if I do it with
pain every step is a price
right now it's mango season what the
hell am I doing around here
three months in a year in India there's
only one religion called mango we will
show up in mangoes in a mango season
what am I doing
anything that you do the limit you will
not do this in Christ anything that will
do unbeliefly is a price
so it's up to you whether you want to
conduct your life willingly
anything that happens to you willingly
Feels by heaven
the same thing if it happens to you
unwillingly feels like hell
yes
this is the choice you have
either you make every breath every bit
of your heart a willing process or an
unwilling process if you make it
unwilling everything will be suffering
if you make it willing everything is
fantastic
couldn't think of Christ there is no
price
life there's no time to pay price in
this life because life is just a certain
arrangement of life and time and energy
energy you can manage time is ticking
away
whether you like it or you don't like it
you're happy you're unhappy you're awake
and you're asleep it's sticking away
isn't it
energies you can conserve you can rest
and become more active the next moment
all these things you can do you can play
with energy time is just sticking away
no time to look back and pay Price look
ahead and do what you can do what is
sort of the primary way that you think
people can start finding simple
happiness
see uh one important thing is uh you
shouldn't be a potato farmer plucking
mangoes from the ground it doesn't work
like that so if you're looking for any
inner experience it has to happen from
within
if only your thought and emotion happen
just the way you want it
your body if it happened the way you
wanted you would be naturally healthy if
your mind if your thought process
happened the way you want it you would
be naturally happy and joyful if your
emotions happen the way you want it you
would naturally be loving and Blissful
by your own nature so right now the
problem is we have not taken charge of
our faculties
and we are trying to take charge of the
world and it's a disaster
everything we're doing is a disaster
whether we realize that or not future
Generations will judge us that what we
have done is a super disaster all in
Pursuit of Happiness and well-being
isn't it and we're all pursuing it
outside yes instead of pursuing it I
mean that's the only place it can happen
isn't it Human Experience happens within
but we are trying to create it from
outside
no matter what you do outside situations
will never ever be hundred percent your
way or my way it never will happen we
can have it to some extent our way
that's about it comfort and convenience
can come by fixing the outside
well-being and joy will not come from
outside it can only come from within so
we have created an education system we
have created a social structure where we
have been taught by ripping the outside
inside will be fixed
and endlessly we're going on we have as
a generation of people we have more
comfort and more convenience than any
generation ever in the history of
humanity but we cannot say we are the
most joyful Generations we cannot even
say we are the most peaceful generation
yo yo I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for some incredible Gower gopal
Das inspiration check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there time does fly time has two wings
and one beak like an airplane the two
wings of the plane on time are passed in
future yesterday and tomorrow are the
two wings and The Barn at that front
Peak is the present